see it how about now manage your air
quality sharpen your performance change
the game with air
[Musique]
things
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et absolument ravi de
vous retrouver pour cette grande finale
extraordinaire celle qu'on attend tous
entre le numéro 1 mondial ancien triple
champion du monde simplement double
champion du monde qui gagne tout sur son
passage en ce moment Magnus Carlsen et
le héros d'un peuple trouver Maxime
vachzagve qui est en grande forme en ce
moment qui dans ce tournoi a été
complètement extraordinaire il a fait
douter c'est le seul à avoir fait douter
Magnus Carlsen on va regarder ça déjà
dans un premier temps on rappelle que
dans ce tournoi c'est un tournoi à
double élimination on a deux vies il a
utilisé une vie Maxime et il est revenu
pour jouer contre Magnus
Carlsen on va regarder ce qui s'est
passé il s'est passé c'est dans la final
c'était mercredi 2 et demi 2 et demi
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire il y a eu
deux partout et un armé gedon ou Magnus
Carlsen c'est ne s'est pas imposé il y a
eu nul mais il avait les noirs et donc
les draws com on dit c'est-à-dire la
possibilité de faire
nul bravo à Magnus pour ce match mais ce
n'est pas terminé Maxime vachz La Grave
hier sous vos yeux n'a fait qu'une
bouchée de Yann pomyashi 2-0 on renvoie
le double vainqueur des derniers
candidat on rappelle he ça donne des
regrets évidemment quand on voit ça Yan
pomashi qui avait gagné les deux
derniers candidats rendez-vous compte
Maxime bah voilà c'est baladé contre lui
c'est pour vous dire à quel point il
joue il joue de manière incroyable en ce
moment et évidemment on va les suivre on
espère un grand match comment ça se
passe le format c'est tout simple c'est
du quatre parties donc on voilà c'est le
dernier jour on se qualifie pour la
finale du CCT à Toronto ça m'étonnerait
pas qu'avec tous ces points là Maxime et
une vraie chance d'accrocher la finale
et le format il est de quatre
rondes quatre parties là pour cette
grande finale si Maxime ça c'est très
important si Maxime l'emporte dans les
dans le premier match en quatre parties
ensuite les deux joueurs auront dépensé
leur vie ils auront perdu chacun une
fois l'un contre l'autre et on aura un
match final en deux parties c'est-à-dire
aller-retour et s'il y a un partout
c'est Armagedon pour jouer le gain du
tournoi mais d'abord il va falloir
battre l'ogre norvégien en qure parties
ce qui n'est pas une m à faire mais si
il joue comme il y a de jours tous les
espoirs sont bien évidemment permis il
jouent pour ce trophée là et ça devrait
commencer normalement à 18h est-ce que
Magnus Carlsen est là ou pas et bien
Magnus Carlsen Magnus Carlsen je vois
pas
alors je vois pas Magnus
ah Magnus Magnus on va
euh on
voit on va
voir alors qu'est-ce qui se passe les
participants on va voir Magnus on va
le
l'épingler hop là et là normalement on
va voir les deux joueurs sous vos yeux
ETB fress dans ces presses techniques
est-ce qu'on voit est-ce qu'il est au
bon endroit et non comme d'habitude
c'est la poisse et pour l'instant on a
alors qui a les blanc dans la première
ça ça va être simple ça va être Magnus
Carlsen qui a les blancs dans la
première le premier CIT a toujours les
blancs c'est possible que ça change les
caméas ou pas je vais attendre avant de
les changer parce que franchement je
suis pas sûr salut à tous évidemment
dans le chat euh l'émotionin l'émotion
me m'a fait oublier la moindre des des
politesses j'en suis désolé salut à tous
dans le chat Gunter love ah c'est un
vieil ami ça niwi no euh
janusville euh lucopathe et salut à tous
aussi à toutes évidemment sur Youtube
euh suliivan
147 alors est-ce qu'on a
euh Maxime je
vais fermer tout ça afficher
permuter ah
non permuter la vidéo et l'écran partagé
et ça va commencer tout de
suite ferm hop là on a les deux joueurs
mais on les a au mauvais endroit bon ben
écoutez je vais les je vais les alterner
je pense que dès que la partie
commence j'aurai le j'aurai la certitude
que c'est bon parce que à chaque fois
c'est c'est pénible de changer de devoir
changer et une partie extraordinaire il
a fait une master cl mvl contre Yan
nepomyashi évidemment se tient au zaget
et ça commence avec Magnus
Carlsen avec les Blancs évidemment on va
mettre mvl du côté noir et on va
alterner les échéquiers et les
euh les images
évidemment voilà et onvoit un gambidam
accepté tout de suite pour Maxime on va
se m du côté de Maxime je sais que vous
aimez bien ça et non ouais décidément
j'auraiis la poisse jusqu'au bout hop là
on va le mettre en haut notre ami Magnus
voyez ça prend ça prend 10 secondes oh
il mange il mange il mange mange Magnus
on sait pas qui te
mangera
alors il a faim il a bien raison les
Norvégiens mangent tôt ils sont habitués
et on va bien cadrer notre
ami notre ami Maxime on va aussi essayer
de bien cadrer notre ami Magnus et
on a Magnus Carlsen qui réfléchit sur G
accepté alors il s'attendait
probablement à une Grunfeld mais ça
existe dans le répertoire de Maxime E3
joué alors E4 c'est la grande ligne mais
c'est très complexe et plutôt le style
de Maxime alors est-ce que aujourd'hui
pas de on avait vu des norf mercredi et
donc effectivement Magnus qui essayé de
prendre Maxime à son propre jeu alors
attention si Magnus Carlsen joue
ouvertur ça va être peut-être une autre
mayonnaise des positions techniques quoi
que Maxime a montré tout son talent ces
derniers jours ça sera encore plus
incroyable de le battre sur un match
comme
ça on va voir tout ça et faut prend C4 à
6 tout est normal ici on joue petit rock
normalement et C5 arrivve et on a la
position de départ où il y a énormément
de coups pour les blancs
euh du gambidam
accepté on va voir ce qu'il fait et C5
il fait A4 Magnus Carlsen ok ok on
empêche
B5 voilà intéressant normalement avec
les noirs on va jouer contre le pion
isolé C6 et puis on prend
des4 est-ce que c'est un tirage au sort
pour les blanc au début pas du tout pas
du tout regardez on va je vais vous
montrer je vous expliquer un truc il y a
le bracket qui est déjà fait comme ça
qui é tiré au sort et celui qui est le
premier cité voilà c'est très simple
c'est déjà appris ça en le jouant
division 2 ou division 3 c'est pareil le
premier cité a toujours les blanc dans
la première comme ça on se fatigue pas
on sait exactement par quoi euh on
commence allez on revient sur la partie
A4 joué par euh Magnus c'est assez connu
quand même même si évidemment ici il y a
énormément de coups il y a E4 qui existe
il y a cavalier C3 j'ai moi-même un peu
tout essayé tour1 B3 évidemment puis on
prend C5 même à3 est un coup euh bon
fou2 j'ai même joué j'ai même fait jouer
à Magnus fou2 contre Fabiano carwana
j'avais préparé ça pour lui une petite
idée il y a quelques années dame 2 c'est
prend des 5 et tour D1 c'est connu pour
pas être très dangereux ça pour les
Noirs mais euh on va voir Magnus un peu
malade ou Magnus pas réveillé mais
attention attention le le champion du
monde l'ancien Champion du monde
Norvégien enfin champion du monde de
Partie Rapide et Blitz attention faut se
méfier quand il a l'air malade il vous
pompe votre énergie
il est il est très fort attention
attention alors est-ce qu'on fait puis
on prend ou on fait cavalier prend ok
c'est un peu étrange la connaissaz pas
comme ça cellelà sur dame 2 quelle est
la théorie laavante principale peut-être
qu'il a raison Maxime c'est ça je me
souvient plus tour D1 fou 7 et puis on
prend des4 ro k C3 et k B4 va arriver
ouais ça c'est assez connu et en général
on essaie de faire fou D7 fou C6 pour
renforcer le contrôle de cette case ou
alors B6 fou
B7 ça dépend il faut ça marche faut
s'assurer à chaque fois de pas se faire
avoir avec un D5
précoce donc
attention attention quand même non le
premier cité c'est celui qui a le qui
était premier au tour d'avant je pense
je sais pas comment sont fait les
tableaux mais vous inquiétez pas tout
est tout est fairpl il y a aucun souci
là-dessus ne vous inquiétez surtout
pas alors peut-être que Maxime va chez
La Grave il y a une blague dans chat 56
qui dit maxime a déjà pris ses billets
pour Toronto c'est vrai que pour Maxime
ça a pas très bien marché cette saison
de champion chz tour mais une victoire
dans un tournoi évidemment que elle
relance pour la la calife voir elle
qualifie donc c'est peut-être doublement
important pour Maxime aujourd'hui de
gagner ce tournoi et de se qualifier
pour
Toronto
kb4 jouer je crois que les les coups
normaux c'est fou G5 ou cavalier E5
c'est à peu près
certain pour Magnus fou F4 peut-être
aussi mais bof bon fou F4 quoi que fou
F4 F5 parfois il un plan ou alors fou G5
ou alors cavalier E5 c'est pas très
clair mais en général c'est considéré
hein de toute façon c'est une très bonne
ouverture he ce ce gambiame accepté
he donc
clairement c'est considéré comme étant
ok mais bon ça ça reste un P isolé très
complexe
évidemment est-ce que les joueurs ont le
droit avoir des spectateurs en fond ou
là j'ai pas capté ta ta question là je
pense qu'à Toronto il il y aura des
spectateurs ouais mais il y aura aussi
des arbitres et tout le monde jouera en
face de l'un de l'autre c'est l'idée du
eSport alors comment on fait ici il
réfléchi Magnus il prend son temps ce
début de partie comme d'habitude il
choisit un plan pour pas se retrouver
attraper plus
tard je sais pas fou G5 serait le coup
mais bon après il faut savoir ce qu'on
fait sur fou D7 il me semblait avoir vu
une variante comme comme ça fou G5 fou
D7 et D5 marche pas vraiment parce qu'
pion prend cavalier prend cavalier prend
fou prend cavalier
prend tour prend fou prend cavalier
prend il y a pas un fou B5 ou un truc
comme ça je sais plus ça me dit quelque
chose ce truc non ça marche pas du tout
ça pourquoi ça marche pas
euh je triche un peu à Dame 4 pardon
donc je sais plus ce que c'est mais il y
avait des arnaques comme ça bon c B4
cavalier E5 jouer c'est peut-être sur
sur ça en fait
où jouer par Magnus sur D5 fou D7 D5 je
crois que ça marche pas des 5 voilà
c'est
ça ça ça ça ça ça al je suis
fou non pas du tout ça marche pas encore
bon ben décidément c'est le début ça
marche pas c'est pas en cette ligne là
il y a dame 4 encore et c'est
fini à moins que ça soit c'est fou G4
ici vous voyez c'est fou G4 je m
souviens de cette arnaque dame C4 et
dame prend des5 dame prend des 5 T8
petit pièges d'ouverture avec tour D1
qui arrive assez connu mais il joue B6
mvl cavalier E4 ok ça c'est étonnant
cavalier 4 pour moi c'est assez nouveau
donc l'idée évidente c'est de venir en 5
avec le cavalier de faire pression sur
F7 si c prend le 4 dame prend attaque la
tour gagne un
tempo alors on va voir ce que
fait Maxime intéressant est-ce qu'on
peut se permettre fou B7 k G5 de laisser
comme
ça F D5 je suppose obligé peut-être
peut-être peut-être qu'on peut faire ça
et c'est joué c'est joué F B7 Maxime qui
joue qui connait peut-être cette ligne
c'est vrai que c'est le coup qu'on a
envie de jouer si kg5 marche pas les
blancs on l'air un peu bête je
trouve il fait oui oui il a l'air
surpris d'ailleurs
mvl
et un petit
prono un petit prono allez un petit
prono on s sur les pronos
ah on a envie de voir un dernier match
donc victoire Armagedon de mvl dans le
premier match et victoire armé Gon de
Magnus dans le deè match
voilà parce que à chaque
fois à chaque fois Magnus Carlsen il
s'en sort quand même mais ça serait
énorme déjà d'aller chercher ce match on
verra c'est un prono voilà c'est le
prono du cœur c'est on a envie de voir
Maxime quand même donner le meilleur de
lui-même et gagner un match et après ça
va être ça va être ça va être évidemment
de toute façon ça va être très chaud
mais on verra peut-être que Maxime peut
le faire s'il gagne le premier match
évidemment il passe pas favori mais pas
loin on verra en tout cas on veut voir
des beaux échecs surtout CAH prend F6 F
prend F6 et tour
à3 est-ce que je peux jouer les
positions que tu as préparé pour Magnus
et oui et oui mon grand je peux faire
tout ce que je veux moi je suis libre
alors fou B7 k pr F6 fou pr F6 et tour
à3 ok on fait passer on fait coulisser
la tour ça c'est une manœuvre qu' fait
ine particulièrement Magnus Carlsen de
faire de de pousser les pions a ou h et
de faire coulisser les tours il est
vraiment coutumier du fait
ouais ouais ouais exactement pour les
candidats après il y a des califes alors
c'est pas forcément les h meilleurs du
monde mais effectivement je suis assez
loin je suis assez loin de me qualifier
il y a une époque hein où j'étais aux
alentours de la 20e place mondiale et
donc j'étais pas si loin j'aV une petite
chance mais j'ai jamais été proche de me
qualifier au candidat malheureusement
c'est gentil de demander mais non non
non je je suis je suis maintenant très
loin de ce niveau je suis à peine dans
le top je sais pas si je suis encore
dans le top 100 ça peut changer tous les
jours je suis 99e je s entre la 98e et
la 100e place en ce moment sans jouer
donc je suis vraiment dépendant des
autres mais voilà l'ambition est
malheureusement malheureusement c'est
dur c'est dur ce jeu les jeunes arriv B5
intéressant donc sur pion prend pu on
prend reprend on va faire dame prend et
on va attaquer G2
ok intéressant intéressant tout ça et
sur fou prend B5 comment on fait comment
on fait sur fou prend B5 et bien on va
le voir c'est joué par Magnus Carlsen
donc évidemment son idée sur tour prend
c'était pas bon hein dame prend à8 F
prend B5 on pouvit même d'abord prendre5
peut-être qui était meilleur plus précis
et ensuite F prend G2 il y a beaucoup de
jeux pour les
Noirs mais après il faut prendre les 5
faut encore montrer des compensations
même si tout ça ça est thématique par
exemple après tour prend puion prend CAH
D5 c'est évident qu'on a les
compensations alors mais c'est quand
même un pion on menace ca C3 un petit
peu désagréable àarît mais euh et il
veut pas du tout faire ça il veut faire
dame D5 mvl menace dame prend G2
etcheque et mat ok
ok non les Noirs en général essaie de
d'égaliser hein encore une fois même
s'ils sont pas vraiment moins bien c'est
quand même plutôt les noirs qui essaient
d'égaliser alors dame D5 alors
clairement il y a une grosse menace
cavalier F3 est pas envisageable on a
pas envie de reculer il y a tour G3 qui
est envisageable
ou alors F2 F3 mais F F3 c'est moche
j'aime pas du tout F2 F3 quoi que c'est
c'est un vrai coup ici
ouais salut St
ouais ah là là oh là là JBM FFE qui qui
ça peut bien être ouais je peux le faire
on va le faire déjà top 100 hein moi je
je signe hein si ça reste comme ça on
bouge plus voilà j'arrête en fait
j'arrête de jouer je vois je regarde ma
situation tous les jours est-ce que ça
augmente est-ce que ça baisse en
fonction des des bons ou des mauvais
résultats de mes de mes concurrents à
ses places
bon je gagne quelques points quand même
pour pour être sûr et c'est ça le
problème on estant gourmand on prend des
risques alors Dame des 5 menace mat
revenons à nos moutons deux manières de
le parer Magnus Carlsen qui réfléchit
je vois pas ce qui se passe sur tour G3
pour être très honnête avec vous menace
certainement fou C4 ouok G4 la j j'aime
pas qu'est-ce que je vous dise
moi je comprends pas pourquoi je vais
tricher je vais mettre la petite jauge
qui met 0,25 pour les blancs quand même
qui dit tour fd8 mais tour fd8 ça me
faisait peur de laisser le cavalier en
vie c G4 peut menacer des c pr F6 ou
cavalier H6
donne F prend des4 la jauge alors là je
Piche toujours pas sur cavalier F6 c'est
quoi le coup c'est fou prend F6 tour
prend des5 tour prend des5 et les noirs
sont bien parce qu'on menace tour à 1 et
tout ça mais bon ok c'est pas très
humain tout ça et on va voir ce que va
faire Magnus mais en tout cas le coup
préféré de la jauge c'est tour G3 F3 me
semble un peu voyez un petit peu
affaiblissant en plus il y a une
tactique il y a une très très belle
tactique ici que je vois pas mais que je
vois aider parce que j'ai toujours pas
éteint la jauge c'est cavalier C2 c'est
ça le truc bon je l'étein maintenant
parce que ça va être pénible sinon K
c'est de très très joli ça c'est des
coups que Maxime peut voir en forme k
prend tour prend à 8 on va plutôt
reprendre de la tour pourquoi pas
prendre la colonne ouverte et s'enlever
de cavalier D7 qui pourrait faire des
fourchettes entre le fou et la tour et
sur dame prend C2 on va faire dame prend
B5 et en général les deux fous compens
très largement le pion en moins on a un
pion isolé un pion faible ici tout va
bien pour les noir donc F3 est vraiment
pas le coup assez clairement Magnus qui
réfléchit 4 minutes d'avance quasiment
pour mvl c'est plutôt bon
signe vu la tête de MV il a raté quelque
chose pas du tout moi je trouve très
focus depuis le début pas trop de mou à
la fin des parties il est normalement il
a pas trop la Poker Face en plus mvl
c'est pas son point fort pour pour
l'avoir joué quand même assez
régulièrement il donne beaucoup
d'indices quand il pendant les parties
il est pas bon niveau Poker Face et
cavalier F3 joué par Magnus Carlsen mais
là dans ce tournoi c'est mieux je trouve
plus plus focus mieux tout est mieux en
fait ça va c'est c'est un tout hein
c'est aussi la détermination qui fait ça
et il est il est déterminé c'est une
évidence alors cavalier F3 coup de recul
un coup
vraiment c'est pas un coup qu'on joue de
guetté de cœur à mon avis Magnus il aime
pas trop ce genre de chose alors j'ai
l'impression donc ça ça va pas ah
ça va être ça va être tout much quand
même de mettre de cavalier à2 al fou C4
il a encore qui prend c un coup de bol
et fou des de il y a quoi fouz ça me
fait un peu peur mais bon ça c'est
concret donc ça peut marcher pour les
Noirs c'est pas impossible que ça
marche et il joue il joue pas du tout ça
il joue il se casse pas la tête il joue
aux échecs simples il joue tour FC
tour sur la colonne ouverte et oui c'est
pas mal jouer on va reprendre maintenant
du Fou et on va menacer tour C2 j'aime
beaucoup il joue nature il joue nature
Maxime pourquoi il serait moins bien il
a beaucoup de jeux des pièces très
actives pour ce pion de moins j'aime
beaucoup les Noirs
ici c'est pas que je pense que les Noirs
soient faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas
dit ENF en même temps comme je parle
tout seul vous faites rien dire mais je
pense pas que les Noirs soient mieux je
pense que la position
en tout cas la Gee paraî dire que c'est
équilibré c'est ce que je penserais
pendant une partie qui a assez de qui a
assez de
compensation
mais c'est plus facile à jouer pour les
Noirs clairement on va menacer des kc2
il y a voyez on a des pièces en l'air on
a quand même cette batterie qui est
désagréable avec le pion G2 donc je
trouve que sur la globalité c'est quand
même en pratique c'est plus agréable à
jouer pour les noirs et en plus il a il
a quand même quasiment il a 4 minutes
d'avance donc c'est quand même c'est
quand même pas mal alors les
joueurs euh les joueurs peuvent euh se
voir bien évidemment euh ils peuvent se
voir bien évidemment non c'est pas
évident mais ils sont dans le col zoom
où je peux les voir aussi tout le monde
peut se voir ENF et moi ils peuvent pas
me voir moi je suis pas je suis pas en
vidéo mais en tout cas on voit les deux
caméras de Magnus et les deux caméras de
Maxime donc si ils veulent ils peuvent
se regarder moi je faisais de temps en
temps sur euh c'était par peur de dans
ces matchs dans ces matchs donc j'ai
joué dans les autres divisions je
faisais j'allais voir parce que parfois
mon adversaireiss 3 minutes j'avais peur
d'avoir perdu la connexion donc on
vérifie le zoom et j'allais voir mon
adversaire et effectivement j'ai pas
perdu la connexion et donc effectivement
il réfléchissait à chaque
fois tout à
fait merci Xibalba qui répond très bien
à la question on voit le gain du match
et à 2 et demi donc 2 et demi c'est en
quatre parties mais ensuite en deux
partout on a ce fermeur à margedon avec
le système des enchères euh ce système
de semibluff et alors quand on a déjà
joué ensemble ça crée un autre voyez
hein Magnus a proposé 828 et euh et
Maxime 10 16 donc effectivement bon ben
là la logique hein c'est que Magnus va
être tenté de proposer un peu plus haut
et peut-être Maxime un peu plus bas ou
pas et en faisant ça en pensant que tu
penses que je pens que tu vas faire ça
je vais faire autre chose donc ça peut
donner un truc marrant pour les enchères
si on a ça aujourd'hui alors fou des de
attaque le cavalier qu'est-ce qu'on a
comme option ici peut-être qui c de pour
attaquer des4 c'est pas impossible k C2
quoi que fou C3 sur protège quand même
le le le pion et ce cavalier est quand
même bizarre en en C2 donc ça c'est
c'est pas terrible finalement non ça me
plaît pas quelles sont les autres
options ici K6 et un coup mais c'est pas
si évident pour les noirs on peut jouer
F 7 aussi pour protéger ce cavalier
intéressant on peut jouer tour C2
évidemment tour C2 euh on joue le
clouage on active notre tour on attaque
le pion écoutez tour C2 je trouve ça pas
mal honnêtement tour C2 joué par notre
ami Maxime va chez la grave
mais ouais bien sûr bien sûr on le voit
on le voit que en ce moment en tout
cas c'est le seul
c'est le seul qui pose vraiment des
problèmes à Magnus qui a poussé dans ces
derniers retranchement dans ce match de
mercredi rejoarmedon donc voilà il a
gagné le tatayle en rapide il a balayé
hier
yanpomashi il avait mis une paté aussi à
mamedarov il a battu ala au premier tour
bon il est assez il est assez
épatant finalement le seul adversaire
pour Maxime c'est aussi Magnus dans ce
tournoi
clairement donc ouis il est il est quand
même il est quand même
incroyable
ah dame F1
jouer est-ce que je préfère jouer à mon
compte ou ton passé de second an je
préfère jouer à mon compte mais bon le
problème c'est que il me le rend pas
bien quand je joue à mon compte je
trouve qu'on me le rend pas assez bien
les résultats me le rendent pas assez
bien
donc c'est
embêtant donc finalement je sais pas
mais oui mais avant tout je suis joueur
comme tout le monde oh team mat 1 on te
regarde depuis kaaissa je le connais en
fait salut amik nos amis de Kaissa
Bordeaux nouveau club créé par Sébastien
Mazé le grand maître international et
thibo Fantinel maître international t
deux bordel alleer faire un tour Kaa
Bordeaux vous googlez ça c'est rue bon
c'est en plein centre c'est simple c'est
en face des qu rappelle plus de la rue
mais en tout cas allez voir ça ambiance
très
sympa j'étais à l'inauguration un très
bon moment et bonne route à eux qui se
sont lancés hein c'est jamais évident de
se lancer dans ce genre de projet moi
j'avouerai lancer un club comme ça faut
avoir du
courage donc bon vent à kaaissa Bordeaux
alors est-ce qu'on fait tour prend B2 et
bien tour prend B2 fou C3 c'est ça
l'idée fous C3 tour B3 oui oui là je
vois pas des tactiques assez simple F C4
attaque la tour et la dame donc ça c'est
pas bon et oui ça il est fort Magnus
pour tre ce genre de petit piège ok donc
maintenant on menace de prendre en B4
toujours c'est revenu la menace
attention Maxime qui prend du temps mais
qui joue dame D6
ok qui va qui protège le cavalier en B4
et qui menace éventuellement fou prend
F3 intéressant et monace T prend mes de
j'aime bien dame D6 alors il prend son
temps aussi he vous voyez aussi le
la gestion du temps de Maxime que je je
je dis beaucoup de bien depuis le début
mais voyez il il a passé du temps là il
a vraiment c'est un moment critique où
les questions se posent tour C dam D6
c'est pas du tout des coups évidents et
donc voilà il prend son temps pour bien
répondre aux questions il joue pas de
coup trop vite ce qui pouvait lui faire
défaut dans ses tournois sur internet
avant il gère très bien son temps et on
sent un adversaire
déterminé et ouais bordeau c'est beau
hein Franch franchementi chaque fois que
j'y vois c'est de plus en plus beau
euh c'est
franchement franchement c'est
sympa
alors le quartier où il son est très
très bah c'est plein centre c'est c'est
aussi simple que ça donc c'est c'est
aussi c'est aussi très sympa donc allez
voir n'hésitez
pas comment on fait ici avec les Blancs
de la part de je sais pas trop
franchement je Seris embêté ici je
trouve que les pièces sont il y a
beaucoup de menaces pour les Noirs tout
simplement donc comment on fait
ici et bien je n'en sais
rien club de tennis échec ka pas encore
pas encore mais ça peut venir ouais ça
peut
venir ça peut éventuellement
arriver en tout cas il y aura des
joueurs de tennis
ça c'est sûr dans le dans le club
d'échec comment on fait là je sais pas
honnêtement je saais pas quoi jouer avec
les Blancs je jouerai un coup est-ce
qu'on peut essayer de garder le pion
comme
ça vous voyez ce genre de truc c'est sûr
qu'on a du jeu he VO on se casse pas la
tête avec les noirs on est au minimum
pas moins bien est-ce qu'on est mieux ou
pas on va discuter plus tard mais ça ça
peut pas être bon et il joue tour C1
Magnus Carlsen qui est d'après la jauge
le meilleur coup encore une fois et sur
tour prend B2 joue tour C8 ah il joue
sur le mat du couloir très très bien vu
de la part de Magnus il est quand même
fort ah on peut pas l'enterrer on peut
jamais l'enterrer Magnus Carlsen
regardez-moi ça donc maintenant c'est
vrai qu'il joue il joue sur ce côté-là
en fait il défend son son fou et son
pion un seul coup et sur fou pr F3 on
prend tout simplement non on prend pas
pardon qu'est-ce que je raconte je
raconte que en plus il menace fou prend
B4 ah il est bon ah tour prend C1 dame
prend C1 ah mais il y a dame prend B4 là
non qu'est-ce que je raconte tour prend
C1 on fait fou prend D6
tour pr
F1 on prend du roi probablement le fou
bouge et fou5 et c'est un énorme pion de
plus donc tour C1 introduit la menace de
fou prend B4 et fou prend D6 joli très
très joli de la part de Magnus tour
prend B2 évidemment il y a tour C8 échec
et on peut abandonner donc si on fait
tour pr C1 qu'est-ce qu'il fait il fait
dame pr C1 je suppose et maintenant si
je fais fou pr F3 il va faire dame C8 ah
trop fort oh là là trop fort mais quel
œil tactique il faut prendre B4 et échec
on gagne une pièce on fait comment on
fait comment oh que c'est bien joué tour
C1 j'aurais même pas envisagé en fait le
problème c'est de l'envisager ce coup là
il est pas évident parce que vous voyez
cette tour elle protège le fou et donc
on se dit non cette tour elle peut pas
bouger tour C1 c'est magnifique en fait
donc c'est très dur une fois qu'on le
voit une fois qu'on le si on voit le
coup on le joue mais le problème c'est
de le voir il faut4 il sur protège ici
oh là c'est bien joué ça aussi sur tour
prend il veut faire cavalier prend et
sur fou prend B4 maintenant hop dame
prend B4 on n plus obligé de prendre
parce que le fou pour reprendre
ici intéressant bien joué de la part de
Maxime assez rapidement
ouais les deux joueurs là qui jouent qui
nous font encore une partie dans la
lignée de mercredi hein ils sont un peu
les deux seuls sur la planète là les
commentateurs sont perdus je vous le dis
commentateur devine pas un coup là
pourtant pourtant normalement j'en
devine des coups mais là là c'est chaud
là ça joue fort là ça joue très fort on
comprend pourquoi vent ils sont là ça
rigole pas et ça ça amuse les deux
joueurs de ils sont avant tout
compétiteurs et voilà c'est clairement
pour Maxime c'est un vrai challenge de
jouer contre Magnus et c'est un vrai
challenge pour Magnus de jouer contre
Maxime quand il est dans cette forme là
c'est une évidence il l'a dit c'était
l'autre jour il a décrit ça Magnus
Carlsen dans son
interview un jour great day for chess
c'està-dire un jour super jour pour les
échecs tout simplement et je crois qu'il
a raison quand c'est joué comme ça avec
autant de suspense avec autant
d'intensité avec autant de qualité même
on des parties joué à plus de 99 % et
bien ça fait plaisir de regarder tout
simplement alors même si on se rend pas
compte de de tout et k C6 encore une
fois magnifique on veut prendre en F3 et
on veut prendre en D4 et certainement
prend des4 direct et effectivement sur
fou prend C6 dame prend dame prend fou
prend et voyez là on va faire nul facile
par exemple cavalier5 puis on prend ça
suffit pas en fout reposé on mettre un
fou ici on va ramener le roi on ne passe
jamais avec les Blancs ici donc ça c'est
archi nul donc donner la paire de fou
c'est pas une solution pour jouer pour
le gain ça c'est une proposition de nul
clairement joli coup kc6 pour bah tout
simplement attaquer le pion aussi simple
que ça puisse paraître je pense que
Maxime va va très largement s'en sortir
je bon alors Magnus effectivement c'est
pas ilabandonne pas facilement ses
espoirs de victoire mais là je vois pas
le
coup très très bien joué cette séquence
K6 j'ai pensé le GID accepté c'est une
bonne ouverture pour pour Maxime ça
donne des positions
dynamiques c'est tout à fait tout à fait
son
style c'est un bon bon apport à la
grunfel qui devenait trop prévisible et
et au final il y avait trop de prépa qui
tombaaiit là à chaque fois ça n'allait
pas trop prévisible tout
simplement c'est le problème c'était
qu'on on était sûr d'avoir la prépa on
savait que si si on jouit même avant les
tournois en fait ça donne envie de se
préparer que cont quand on regarde des
choses one des grunfel parce que moi qui
l'ai vécu en tant que second Magnus je
souvent des grunf parce qu'au moins on
voit mon travail je suis sûr qu'on va
voir mon travail si je dois travailler
avant le tournoi je reg une GRF comme ça
au moins il y a Maxime puis il se prend
l'idée c'est sûr donc voilà ça aussi ça
ça ça incite les joueur à se préparer
contre lui donc c'est à passer plus de
temps donc c'est c'est c'est un mauvais
deal on peut pas faire ça
alors un peu de respect
Oliver on est gentil avec les avec les
avec les joueurs pas le physique on a
dit donc tu vas te prendre 600 secondes
mon cher
ami tu vas te prendre 600 secondes on
fait pas
ça
voilà
allez fait pas ça c'est pas très gentil
parle pas comme ça merci alors fou
F4 fou
F4 attaque la dame et Dame des 5 ouais
dam des 5 allez enfin un coup trouvver
ouais HRA HRA HRA F prend pr f prend ok
bon fou D6 ok sur fou pr F3 qu'est-ce
qu'il veut faire P on prend fou prend
des 4 B4 et là il a des vraies chances
avec le pion passé éloigné c'est ça son
espoir quoi que même pas d la juge F65
et le roi vient F6 B5 ro F7 fou C7 38 B6
on est dernier temps avec les Noirs donc
ça ça ça ne va pas donc là c'est du
calcul précis
ouais ouais on va prendre et on va
prendre fou D6 c'est vraiment pour
mettre le fou en C5 essayer de pousser
mais ça c'est pas assez c'est jamais
assez et fou prend F3 même si on est un
peu rétisant à le faire je suis pas sûr
que Maxime va le faire c'est aussi pour
empêcher le roi de venir mais en fait F
prend F3 et F prend D4 marche au
tempo F prend P on prend F prend les4 B4
F6 F C5 non j'en SICI et les finales de
pion en fait sont mieux pour les Noirs
parce qu'on va encaisser le pion ro G2
ro7 ro G3 ro D7 3 F4 en fait on passe
pas avec ce roi voyez on peut essayer de
passer mais on y arrive pas et c'est
joué par Maxime il calcule il calcule
très bien B4 F6 c'est joué par Maxime
waouh grosse décision quand même euh
grosse
décision grosse décision pas Maxime mais
excellente F4 donc maintenant on veut
faire passer le roi par là on va amener
le roi et on va faire roi 8 3 D7 il y a
aucun problème la structure à roi ne per
permet pas de jouer pour le gain pour
les pour les blancs qui sont limite
moins bien en fait ici malgré le pion
passé
éloigné avec cette structure qui permet
pas de passer quo que limite moins bien
ouais quand même pas ro C7 peut-être ro
C7 menace ro B6 et sur F 5 fou B6 on
peut jouer finale de pion évidemment ro
C7 fou 5 fou
B6 fou
B4 on va faire un truc comme ça comment
on fait non mais je crois pas qu'on
puiss jouer le gain mais enfit en tout
cas si quelqu'un peut jouer le gain
c'est plutôt mvl oui c'est ça FO 5 il se
dépêche de répéter Magnus il joue roi D6
men roi C5 sur fou B4 il va jouer roi D5
ou là ça va être un pion de plus pour
mvl et pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas il
met la pression d'entrée il avait à mon
avis pas beaucoup de chance de gain mais
sa position était plus facile à jouer
remarquz Magnus qui comme d'habitude
cherché beaucoup mais là c'est peut-être
un peu trop mais est-ce que cette 4
contre 3 elle va pas être nulle facile
pour les blancs en fait c'est ça que je
suis en train de me dire que même si on
perd ce pion en B5 et bien ça va être
nul quand même assez
facile c'est ce que je pense on va voir
genre un truc comme ça on perd le pion
ouais il est pas fou de joie Magnus
Carlsen évidemment mais je crois que
c'est c'est quand même nul assez facile
B6 roi
C6 non c'est pas ça la variante
on fait quoi c'est quoi l'idée sur roi
C5 je l'ai
pas roi E4 ok sur roi prend il ou là il
donne ce pion et il fait F5 wouh grosse
décision là et c'est perdant c'est
perdant d'près la jauge mais c'est pas
une grosse surprise que ça soit perdant
franchement puis on prend et repr prend
et ça pourrait être une énorme surprise
Magnus qui essaie de défendre d'e
manière active son son concept c'est que
la case H1 et de de la mauvaise couleur
vous voyez et donc il espère avoir un
fou C3 fou prend F6 en fait en gros ce
qu'il espère c'est ça fou C3 tu fais roi
C4 et je fais fou pr F6 puis on prend
roi prend et ça ça va être nul ah quoi
que on a on a pas le temps de
revenir je sais pas ça ça me semble nul
quand même
ouais la Jae elle a craqué là on va H3
et non en fait ça va être perdant parce
qu'on va être chassé de de h on narrive
pas à aller en H1
alors attention alors E5 c'est l'autre
coup il joue pr F5 prend considère que
ça gagne C3 vaêre joué par Magnus
Carlsen C4 vaê jou à mon avis ou alors
h446 F7 quand même4 jou6 C4 il va gagner
du temps Magnus qui a complètement
craqué dans cette finale incroyable ça
gagne ça gagne ça gagne maintenant ça y
est
ça gagne je pense ro C4 ro C4 lae dit
que ça gagne donc il y a pas de
secret ou non Magnus qui a complètement
craqué et ça peut faire 1 pour maximez 6
C4 le fou doit bouger et on va avoir
certainement ro D34 et on va
pousser al on fait G6 F5 aussi qui a
l'air complètement gagnant ça a l'air
complètement
gagnanttement gag alors est-ce qu'on
fait roi D3 ou G6 ça c'est la c'est la
vraie
question on va
voir il prend son temps 34 secondes pour
Maxime va chez La Grave faut qu'il fasse
un peu attention au temps mais ça
devrait aller normalement ro D3 menace4
roi F7 il va faire F5 et il va pousser
tout ça
c'est sû ça gagne ça il a calculé et il
va faire fou G5 fou3 3 prend F3 fou B6
il va faire fou G5 euh il faire ro 2 et
F F2 R2 et F F2 plutôt
ouais ça doit gagner comme
ça roi E2 ici fou F2 ici ici ici un truc
comme ça et fou G5 fou F2 jouer roi E2
fou G3 ah oui c'est la même et fou F4
maintenant fa F4 pour encaisser le pion
pour être sûr et là ça gagne facile
après faut faire attention si le roi
blanc arrive ici c'est nul mais le roi
blanc est pas à temps quo que sur fou
prend roi G6 fou G1 roi F5 je pense
c'est nul là déjà donc faut faire
attention à pas prendre le pion ou il
s'est mis dans les ennuis il joue fou
des deux pour faire fou ou c'est bien
joué ça c'est geste technique victoire
de Maxime vachz la grave mais impérial
incroyable on va faire ça au ralenti
bravo à lui sur B4 c'était encore nul B4
F6 ok où est-ce qu'il a je sais pas où
est-ce qu'il a il a mal joué Magnus mais
petit à petit j'ai l'impression F4 F7
encore nul quoi que il commence à quand
même assez clairement préfér4 est une ga
ouais fallait filer le pion ce que je
disais le 4 contre
3 est-ce qu'il est perdant ou pas ce 4
contre 3 j'en sais rienê
honnêtement mais ça peut être nul parce
que ce genre de truc ça se défend bien
quand même avec les noirs ir du mal à
créer un pion passé voyez ces pions
doublés en défense ils sont pas mal en
fait ils sont presque donc je sais pas
si ça gagne ou pas ça peut-être
peut-être pas et donc après ro4 F prend
F2 là c'est fini F5 prend F5 et le plus
précis
E5 E5 et non B6 3 C6 fou B4 et on va on
va se venger sur le pion en en G7 donc
ça n'irait pas puis on prend et là il a
joué de manière al il y avait d'autres
manières
moi je pense que ça ouais ok est-ce que
j'ai6 gagn aussi facile G6 était mauvais
fou des 8 oh ben bravo bravo te ro des
TR
oua il il a hyper bien joué il a joué la
première ligne
làou 5
ouais
superbe superbe technique mais comme
d'habitude on le sait on sait qu'il est
là bravo Maxime on lui appuie le point
bien évidemment on va mettre un petit
point et c'est une énorme sensation
quand même avec Maxime qui prend la tête
et il reste de
blanc bravo bravo
Maxime énorme donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est on va regarder quand c'est
que ça commence la prochaine la
prochaine elle est dans elle est dans Je
sur zoom non là il mdate
plus je pense que la la prochaine est
dans
ou
là la prochaine est dans très exactement
minutes donc sur ce il faut que je fasse
des PO publicitair pour nos amis d'opéra
opéra meilleur navigateur au monde pour
nos amis d'ings alors là avec ça on
respire bien en tout cas on sait si on
respire bien ou pas et après on peut en
tirer les conséquences et nos amis de
secret Lab qui doivent toujours
m'envoyer le siège chers amis secret Lab
n'hésitez pas àen voyz un siège gratuit
voir
plusieurs je prends toujours quand c'est
gratuit voilà surtout quand c'est beau
et vous voyez derrière vous voyez chez
Maxime vachz la grave il a la chaise
secret Lab il y a du favoritisme en même
temps on les comprend j'enverrai d'abord
à Maxime mais je me l'enverrai aussi à
moi donc n'hésitez pas secret Lab voilà
je minite pour ma chaise sur ce
euh sur ce use 5 petites minutes on
revient dans c'est en 7 minutes la
partie je revi en 5 minutes tout de
[Musique]
suite
t
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour après ces pubs
obligatoires hein peut-être je ferai un
puzzle rush dans une autre pause mais
pour l'instant faut que je passe les
pubs on sait jamais REM marquez le match
là euh
le match oui il risque de durer
effectivement mais bon je peux pas me
permettre je suis désolé je suis obligé
de vraiment passer ses
pubs je sais que vous j'espère en tout
cas que vous préférez ma compagnie mais
c'est comme ça voilà on verra dans les
prochains streams oui
effectivement si secret Lab pourra
m'envoyer un siège
franchement ça serait un geste on fait
une pti là qui lance une
pétition faut je change ces sièges
commence à être
vieux ça ça m'arrangerait moi en tout
cas en tout cas merci à eux de soutenir
le tournoi et de nous permettre de
regarder ce match extraordinaire entre
Maxime vach grave
et Magnus
Carlsen on voit victoire de maximeve
dans la première donc il mène 1-0 dans
ce match en qure parties alors
effectivement c'est Leyen d'être terminé
attention
hein Magnus qui est jamais aussi
fort que
quand que quand il est en
difficulté allez Magnus qui va manger un
petit truc ça y est et ça va bientôt
repartir c'est dans une petite minute
que ça repart normalement on va pas
rater
ça
et je peux pas dire mon siège
actuel je peux pas dire ma mon siège
actuel je vais pas donner le nom de
concurrent de de marque
concurrente c'est moins bien je suis sûr
c'est moins bien que c'est CR ENF en
tout cas fa tester donc voilà je peux
pas vous dire pour l'instant mais a
priori
mieux on en tout cas est-ce que Maxim
ave les blancs je pense qu'il va jouer
normalement il va pas Esser de faire nul
quo que ça serait
tant évidemment
mais il y a pas de raison il est en
forme il peut enfoncer le clou dans la
deè pourquoi pas pourquoi pas enfoncer
le CL dans la deè est-ce que Magnus va
jouer une Sicilienne très probablement
qu'est-ce qu'il va jouer j'en sais rien
en fait pour être très très honnête
il est assez imprévisible ça se trouve
lui-même le sait pas au moment où on
parle alors pourquoi ça commence pas une
minute de retard et ça y est c'est parti
pour la deuxième partie que je vais vous
mettre je vous
rappelle aussi le
live toujours en bas en bas de moi vous
avez l'chquier en direct enam à droite
vous avez
l'chquier où je fais des flèches et on a
une berlinoise ok ok question
question tour et F F1 cavalier F5 joué
par Magnus Carl une petite ligne qui
garde des pièces la ligne la moins
marrante c'est prend 5 prend 5 et petit
rock mais cavalier F5 garde plus de
pièces mais ça permet plus
d'ESS pour les blancs D5 D4 on va on le
F en
D6 intéressant intéressant tout ça on va
voir comment joue comment joue Maxime il
joue H3 ok qui est un peu surprenant
cette position mais pourquoi pas donc
clairement Maxime qui aurait pu faire
nul tout de suite hein dans cette
berlinoise il a pas voulu il a préféré
la jouer évidemment il reste encore
trois parties donc si ah oui s' y a de 0
il continue de jouer bien sûr bien sûr
qu'il continue de
jouer alors il y a un check hein il y a
comment il vérifie qu'il triche pas il y
a plusieurs choses la première c'est
deux caméras il y a une caméra en face
comme on la voit et une caméra derrière
ensuite ISO sculte on doit montrer
l'environnement et la salle de jeu on
doit laisser le son aussi sur la caméra
sur une des deux caméras donc voilà
quelqu'un peut pas crier un coup
et aussi il y a évidemment le logiciel
de chesscom hein qui qui qui veille au
grain et qui est bien fait qui attrape
beaucoup de gens tous les jours ne le
faites pas c'est nul déjà intérêt de
tricher et en plus vous ferz attraper
pour les petits malins vous ferez
toujours attraper vous inquiétez pas tôt
ou
tard donc voilà aucun
intérêt et là on voit c'est quand même
en finale hein je crois que c'est la
meilleure preuve hein
de du Fair playay de ces tournois c'est
déjà alors un titre personnel moi j'ais
jouer 5 des playin euh je peux vous dire
j'ai jamais eu le début d'un
commencement de soupçon franchement ça
joue j'ai mes chances hein tout le temps
j'ai mes chances j'en donne enfin bon
vous voyez c'est des parties normales et
on voit Magnus Carlsen qui est champion
du monde de parti rapide en TI champion
du monde de Blitz en tit qui gagne quand
même la plupart des tournois mvl qui a
été champion du monde de Blitz en 2021
qui est quand même bah en rapide une
référence en blitz
aussi bon voilà c'est pas on a pas des
joueurs
des joueurs amateurs en en finale donc
c'est aussi euh c'est un
gage B ça se passe ça se passe euh ça se
passe pareil il peut avoir des et
parfois moi il m'ont montré ils m'ont
demandé hein ça arrive que de temps en
temps ça m' arrivve une fois ils m'ont
demandé de de montrer mes
oreilles à la caméra ça arrive il
peuvent faire ça
aussi mais euh la la sanction est pour
ces joueursl là c'est pas en plus hein
non seulement euh un c'est nul deux on
se fait attraper tôt ou tard et en plus
le dernier truc euh c'est que pour ces
joueurs-là la réputation euh vous rendez
compte hein euh vous vous rendez compte
hein ça veut dire une carrière une
carrière qui euh qui s'arrête tout
simplement voilà donc euh non non non ça
n'a pas de sens
euh à tous les
niveaux alors on fait H3 H6 C3 et et
tour8 3 fou D6 pourquoi H6 pour empêcher
fou G5 pourquoi H3 ça j'ai plus de mal à
expliquer parce que je connais cette
position mais le pion H2 avec un coup de
développement genre kibd2 j'ai
l'impression que c'est une bonne version
pour les
Noirs donc c'est très probable que les
Noirs a égalisés dans cette
position déjà dans l'autre version c'est
pas mal pour les Noirs mais
là mou une idée du nom de l' Maxim oui
on l'a ici on
l'a on l'a depuis de nombreux jours et
ça va on va te répondre dans le
chat les gens du chat vont te répondre
ils le savent ceux qui ont suivi les
derniers jours
ouais les oreilles n'allons pas plus
loin effectivement carï
oui que les
oreilles le reste non il en a une caméra
il demande il demande à ce que la
seconde caméra on voit la
souris ils veulent voir la
souris je sais pas trop pourquoi j'avais
pas compris ce truc mais c'est ils
insistent sur ça bon bref je monte ma
souris et puis je fais comme tout le
monde quoi voyez pas poser la question
alors dame C2 attaquant le cavalier dame
E6 C BD2 dame F6 et ouais ça c'est
thématique pour faire fou des7 et tour 8
on va sortir les pièces gentiment
cavalier F1 et il décide d'être plus
ambitieux Magnus Carlsen il fait
cavalier F7 menace vous prend H3
intéressant et menace F F5 aussi j'ai
l'impression qu'il a résolu tous ses
problèmes la je n'est pas
d'accord mais
euh mais pourquoi pas et voilà tout qui
suit
facile facile facile facile le chat le
sa facile oh bravo tout le monde le sait
c'est un secret de poli Chinel
maintenant et voilà bravo bonne réponse
du chat mais faut pas le dire attention
c'est un
secret cavalier 1 H2 qui surprotège ici
et qui menace des kg4 éventuels c'est
pas mal ça j'aime
bien G4 est quand même embêtant on n pas
envie de donner ce fou parce que puis on
prend et menace
G5 donc c'est compliqué fou F5
ok exactement luinipples voilà tout à
fait mon cœur balance et je serai
content quoi qu'il arrive voilà c'est ça
exactement j'ai envie de voir un beau
match c'est c'est tout à fait ça tuas
tellement bien résumé la situation c'est
beau j'aurais pas mieux
fait dame G6 et maintenant dame prend F5
simplement il y a rien du tout pour
Maxime ça va échanger ça va pas prendre
de risque à mon avis et ça va faire une
une sorte de
turboro parce que dame B3 çaurait le
coup pour poser des problème alors
peut-être hein euh Maxime qui pourrait
montrer la la grosse confiance là en
jouant d B3 d B3 attaque par ici monace
F pr H6 mais ça déserte un petit peu l'
roi alors
attention attention attention mais
bon euh comment on peut
faire bah oui Laurent Blanc c'est
évident maxime est fan de de l'Olympique
Lyonnais on le rappelle donc c'était une
évidence il a tout lâché Lauran blanc
pour revenir avec pour venir avec
mvl c'est un
secret fou D2 ouais bon ben alors là
c'est pas très marrant dame B3 S se
passait quoi je suis un peu curieux
tiens on va mettre on va mettre la
petite jauge dame B3 comment protéger
tout ce beau monde ah ouais des coups
comme dame D3 empêche F prend H6 et sur
dame prend B7 hop là h là m du couloir
et oui non vous voyez c'était pas bon ça
délaissé moi je c'est un truc que je
vois pas ça dame D3 mais je le sens et
il fait F6 pour empêcher cavalier 5 et
roi F1 et même symboliquement les les
noirs sont un peu mieux pourquoi parce
que les seuls pions fixés de cette
position c'est D4 et D5 et vous voyez
bien que ce pion est de ce blanche et
donc le fou rayonne un peu plus peut
jouer un peu plus tandis que ce pion là
est de case noire et sur case noire on a
le fou de case noire donc le Fou est un
peu moins bon que son homologue en D6
mais bon franchement normalement ça se
gagne pas après après c'est Magnus
Carlsen il va bien entendu essayer de de
poussauter
gentiment alors
ok ce7 c'est tout à fait logique pour
ensuite jouer C6 ou éventuellement B6 C5
il sera un peu plus d'attaque on peuter
k G6 H5 et voilà ce genre de
chose bon
mais très pragmatique
hein très pragmatique Maxime qui va bon
qui doit regretter un peu de pas avoir
pris la Turbo effectivement ça s'est mal
passé mais bon c'est un bon état
d'esprit il a bien eu raison enfin moi
qu'il est tort et qu'il la
perde mais clairement il y avait pas de
raison de d'essayer de forcer la nu
d'entré mant effectivement avec cette
position c'est pas très agréable tout
simplement ah bon il y a un bouquin de
Magnus qui va sortir bientôt c'est pas
un cours chass
plutôt je crois que c'est plutôt un cour
ch
non no frères de Ch
cavalier E3 ok alors maintenant c'est
l'heure du choix est-ce qu'on fait B6 C5
est très risqué mais pour faire en sorte
que quelque chose se passe prend3 on va
reprendre du fou on va remettre un truc
en en F5 à du roi c'est la même chose
ensuite on met le RO en D3 je suppose
que Magnus va essayer de faire quelque
chose sur ce côté là peut-être H5
d'abord d'ailleurs G5 pour éviter de se
faire fixer par
G4 peut être un peu embêtant la Gee dit
que non mais bon par principe on
commence normalement par H5 et non il
joue G5 il me fait
mentir donc il a dû voir un truc sur G4
il y avait H5 certainement sur G4 ça
créé du jeu et maintenant on veut faire
k G6 certainement peut-être G4 et
peut-être que les les blancs sont pas
mal les noirs sont pas mal enfin les
noirs sont un peu mieux c'est sûr c'est
défendable c'est sûr mais quand
même
quel reportage quel film de quoi vous
parlez là ah oui ouioui c'est ça il y a
un film ouii ça j'ai entendu parler du
reportage qu'ils ont fait en Espagne
avant son match
ouais
ah oui ouais ouais ouais il y a aussi ah
oui non vous parlez pas de ça vous
parlez pas du reportage de Magnus mais
du reportage de de mvl ouais il y avait
reportage sur mvl à France 2 ils avaient
tourné ça au club de Clichy
j'étais le coach mystère ce qui était
pas du tout vrai c'est la télé on
raconte n'importe quoi la télé tout le
monde le sait donc voilà voilà pour la
petite histoire j'avais joué le coach le
coach mystère c'était pas vrai du tout
je jou le coach mystère parce que
j'étais dispo j'étais à
Paris t rchant on va empêcher
G4 enfin en tout cas on veut être prêt
en 4 G4 à occuper la colonne
h ça reste évidemment très solide pour
les pour les Noirs les noirs qui vont
pas jouer G4 tout de suite évidemment
ils vont essayer de faire des coups
d'amélioration alors lesquels bien je
sais pas peut-être un coup de A5 moi
jeis tenté de faire un petit peu de
d'espace quo que à 5 peut-être à 4 il
fait cavalier F5 Magnus Carlsen ok il
sait ce qu'il fait j'ai du mal à
critiquer les coup de Magnus dans ce
genre de position il est tellement
fort
ouais ouais ouais arnag mon cours qui va
sortir mais là il est
[Musique]
en ça avance pas beaucoup là je dois
vous
avouer
Laue la flemme peut-être la
paresse je crois que la paresse c'est la
principale
raison oh là là là il y a des gens qui
ont des dossiers dans le dans le dans le
chat je vous raconte pas cavalier E1
pourquoi cavalier1 pour faire k C2 et
cavalier E3 et jouer très solide
9 minutes pour les deux joueurs
légèrement et on voit Magnus he qui se
presse pas pour faire C6 donc il veut se
garder l'option de faire B6 et C5 le
problème de A5 c'est qu'il aura toujours
A4 en
fait et donc ouais non c'est pas un bon
deal alors comment on fait ici pour avec
les Noirs je vous avouerai que j'en sais
rien je serai tenté je regarderai B6 C5
ici mais c'est risqué
hein on va
voir ah xicos qui demande tu CER quel
joueur si tu pouvais choisir ben je je
l'ai
fait je l'ai fait j'ai choisi j'ai
choisi le celui
euh celui que je voulais coacher c'est
parfait c'est c'est bon j'ai j'ai eu ce
que euh j'ai eu mieux mieux que ce que
je
voulais c'était quelque chose de de pas
de pas
refusable de de voir privilège de
coacher Magnus Carlsen pendant 10 ans et
pendant tous ces matchs Championnat du
Monde ces 5 matchs championnat du monde
euh c'était
euh
incroyable juste
incroyable alors comment on fait est-ce
qu'on C5 non mais c'est5 direct est trop
risqué puis on prend fprend je peux même
me permettre de faire k C2 parce que FPR
F2 hop là enfilade ça ne va pas donc C5
serait trop compliqué il réfléchit
Magnus ah quand il commence à réfléchir
dans ce genre de position il prend il
prend des décisions risquées il est
capable éid de prendre des risques non
ça fait un moment que casparov est plus
en relation avec Magnus
Carlsen clairement ça fait depuis plus
de 10
ans maain non il y a plus de match il
joue moins donc oui non j' plus Magnus
il joue beaucoup moins de partie
classique beaucoup moins de
match faire plus de match donc ouais
puis il faut faut savoir
euh 10 ans hein vous rendez compte hein
10ans ça fait beaucoup hein mais
peut-être euh s'il rejoue s'il rejoue
ses matchs euh moi je suis chaud ce que
je lu dit sans les matchs franchement
euh j'ai toujours des contacts avec lui
évidemment mais euh sans les matchs ça
perdait un peu de
son de son
charme très honnêtement
alors C6 joué par Magnus
Carlsen et peut-être qu' c'est de
cavalier3 certainement comment il va
faire cavalier H4 on attaque le pion G2
et sur G3 on va faire cavalier F3 ok il
attendait ça Magnus c'est clair cavalier
E3 il veut certainement faire fou F4 ou
remettre son cavalier par là peut-être
fou F4 pour Esser de prendre et non sur
H4 il fait G3 il autorise ce cavalier en
F3 ok on remarquer il varouver enferm ce
cavalier il est bizarre ce
cavalier donc effectivement revenu en F5
d'ailleurs Magnus bon il a provoqué G3
mais bon
franchement cavalier E3
ouais c'est quand même pas grand-chose
ro G6 il dit ok pour les échanges je
vous le dis souvent ça ok pour les
échanges mais dans mes conditions
prend roi prend
et et les noirs sont pas
mal pas mal sans plus c'est quand même
assez annulant ce truccl
là il y a beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup
de
questions ouais il est très talentueux
les deux les deux yes Mama vous rendez
bien compte pour arriver à ce niveaul
faut seulement avoir du talent mais ê
très travailleur aussi c'est toujours
les deux hein c'est tout he faut tout
avoir vous rendez compte pour dominer
une discipline de la tête et les épaulle
pendant plus de 10 ans comme le fait
Magnus Carlsen en étant numéro 1 mondial
de manière ininterrompue depuis 2011
jusqu'à
2023 faut du talent du travail un peu de
chance faut tout voilà faut tout en même
temps c'est c'est aussi simple que
ça c'est aussi simple que ça est-ce
qu'il est sympa ouais ouais moi je
trouve très sympa alors après euh oui
oui après il fait une fois qu'il fait
confiance il est vraiment il il se livre
et voilà
mais mais en en vrai moi je l'ai vu avec
les les fans des il donne beaucoup de
temps aussi hein au
fans
toujours jamais non pour une photo un
autographe donc
ouais et franchement vu les
sollicitations qu'il a Mo je vous
avouerai que je serais pas de d'aussi
bonne composition au bout d'un moment je
crois j'en aurai un peu marre quand même
je l'ai vu dans des tournois où c'était
vraiment c'était assez
incroyable c'est aussi un peu difficile
de se promener dans la rue en fait ça
doit être c'est quelque chose quand même
à Oslo
en Norvège en général il y a 5 millions
d'habitants et donc tout le monde
connaît Magnus Carlsen ça je vous le
garantis donc se promener dans la rue
c'est un
sujet alors B3 c'était pour faire C4
pour améliorer un petit peu sa situation
mais il fait B5 il met tout sur blanc
Magnus ça a du sens tout
ça mais ça reste quand même très très
équilibré je vois pas le plan des des
Noirs là honnêtement il y a pas de en
fait comment il va
faire Maxime et Maxime va en va envie de
va voir pardon va avoir envie de d'en
finir tout de suite peut-être tour à 1
pour jouer à
4 tour 1 pour jouer à 4 ça a l'air pas
mal
salut salut yocha
ouais ouais moi je trouve oui
après qu'it jamais à 200 % mais oui non
c'est quelqu'un
de euh de gentil et de dans la vie et
très méchant sur
échqu qu' y a pas
[Musique]
de c'est clair qu'il a pas il a pas
beaucoup d'empathie pour ses adversaires
quand il joue aux échecs en tout cas
mais il considè c'est un jeu il aime
jouer aussi c'est aussi ça qui fait qui
fait sa grande force il adore le jeu et
G4 jouer par Maxime ok intéressant il a
pris prix il avait il avait donné la
colonne il tourb mais il avait calculé
ça que sur G4 maintenant puis on prend
on prend T6 et attention on attaque ça
on attaque ça on attaque ça c'est une
très très belle case oh là là bon pied
bon il pour Maxime il est fort Maxime
dans ce
tournoi il est incroyable dans cette
période
aussi
tour
6 et F F4 jouer par Magnus mais là ça va
redonner un pion ça va transposer en
finale de tour c'est dur de croire puis
se passer quelque chose le seul scénario
pour les Noirs c'est de faire ro F3 ro
pr F2 et de pousser ce
ponger mais alors je pense qu'on
va on va réussir à s'organiser quand
même avec les Blancs alors très
certainement faire ro F3 je pense que
c'est toute l'idée du
truc et comme ça ro F3 tour prend C6 ro
pr F2 et on espère une embellie sur le
piong qu'est-ce que je vous dise mais ça
paraît quand même très très nul he cette
histoire tour B6 OK et oui tour B6 pas
mal comme ça sur un 5 on a tour à 6 on
peut essayer d'attaquer ce pion et il
pose des petits problèmes Magnus
Carlsen
a 5 tour à6 attaque le
pion c'est quoi l'idée là je comprends
pas
ou est-ce que ça marcherait pas un truc
comme
ça enferm ah non mais je me sors comme
ça ou non c'est débile c'est débile
c'est débile c'est
débile
un truc comme ça on va encer ce pion non
non ça va pas j'ai eu une hallucination
donc attention évidemment on perd pas
vraiment le pion parce qu'on on prend ce
pion mais attention ça peut faire un
pion passer éloigné ça peut faire un
deuxième avec le pion F ça peut être un
petit peu
dangereux
attention attention quand
même
Maxime en
légère
en défense il est en défense mvl là
c'est une
évidence bon Magnus a pas l'air emballé
par sa
position il espéit peut-être plus au
début de la finale
ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai rappelonsle
Magnus qui a gagné la Coupe du Monde qu'
avait pas gagné qu' avait jamais gagné
online il gagne
tout il il est quand même assez il a
gagné le speed chess il est en finale du
Bullet qui est pas
forcément sa meilleure discipline il est
quand même assez incroyable Magnus ces
derniers mois et notamment la Coupe du
Monde he ça dure un mois gagner la Coupe
du Monde c'est pas
rien est-ce que fa pr F4 fait nul ouais
tout fait nul mais peut-être 3 mais je
sais pas on peut la perdre par
exemple2 tour prend tour prend C6 tour
A2 voyez là
déjà voilà la che commence ça mais il va
faire échec d'abord ouais il fait roi E2
d'abord et sur tour prend à 5 j'ai
compris son idée va faire tour G6
d'abord un petit échec pour pas que le
roi vienne à F3 et roi F5 tour prend C6
et sur tour A2 on peut maintenant venir
en F3 on va faire tour C5 et on va faire
nul facile c'est ça sa technique de
défense à
mvl comme toujours très très précis dans
les finales de tour dans les finales en
général alors tour prend à 5 tour G6
échec joué très important ces petits
échecs hein
intermédiaire à ne pas rater et à voir
quand vous êtes en défense ou en attaque
d'ailleurs pour déplacer le roi sur une
case moins confortable et on le voit
toute la différence et qu'on va avoir ro
F3 tandis que si on faisait tour prend
C6 il y avait tour à 2 qui arrivé et
voyez sur roi ro F3 on était dans les
gros ennuis là onass échec et roi prend
tour2 enfin bref ça n'allait plus et roi
F5 tour prend C6 joué et maintenant tout
va bien sur tour A2 on a ro F3
si roi revient en G4 on peut refaire
échec et répéter la position ça va être
nul ça va être nul et c'est bon pour le
français tout ça c'est bon pour notre
dernier match en deux parties après ne
vendons pas la peau du
Magnus ne jamais vendre la peau de
Magnus Carlsen beaucoup s'en sont mordu
mordu les
doigts C derniers mois genre les 50
derniers mois ouais c'est ça Magnus il
domine genre les 150 derniers mois c
derniers mois tour des deux menace tour
des TR échec 4 c'est vrai que c'est une
domination comme rarement on a eu hein
en terme de longévité he il y a eu
Kasparov qui a été 20 ans numéro 1
mondial là il en est à 12 déjà Magnus et
il y a quand même beaucoup plus de
tournois beaucoup plus de concurrence
donc c'est c'est très très
impressionnant tout ça alors bon ben ça
va s'arrêter hein
mais on peut parier sur les 15 ans moi
je pense que entre 15 et 20 voilà il
arrivera pas à 20 il arrivera à 15 de
numéro 1 mondial après s'il arrête de
jouer en en partie classique ou quasi je
pense que on prend cette direction là
très
honnêtement je pense pas qu'il va jouer
beaucoup hein l'année prochaine en
partie
classique vu ce qu'il dit en privé vu ce
qu'il dit en public ce qui est souvent
la même chose il aime pas ça il est
parti rapide il préfère les jouer je
crois qu'il a raison il préfère les
jouer les gens on préfère regarder voilà
aussi il y a plus de public pour les les
parties les parties rapides euh le
format est quand même magnifique oh F3
et regardez-moi ça mais qu'est-ce qu'il
est bon Maxime précis jusqu'au bout ro4
poser les petites questions avec tour C2
qui pouvait
arriver mais il a joué un petit coup un
petit coup très malin F3 plus de roi E4
on peut pas protéger des5 et ça va être
nul cette histoire c'est certain tour
des3 tour prend des 5 ro 6 tour à 5 tour
prend des 4 et T prend à 7 vous l'aurez
vu ici en premier
ouais ouais quand ils sont quand ils
sont dans cette forme c'est vraiment un
combat de titan et ça fait plaisir pour
Maxime qui aura l'île deain bientôt sa
dernière chance pour se qualifier au
tourin des candidats et quand on voit ça
quand on voit le filartordre alors c'est
pas rien c'est pas parce que c'est
online que ça compte moins moins fort je
vous Magnus il met la même intensité si
c'est online en live ou sous une tente à
capandou il y a pas de problème Magnus
Carlsen quand il s'assoit devant un
échquer c'est pour gagner
donc c'est quand même très rassurant et
ça peut lui donner confiance c'est
certain que ça va lui donner confiance à
Maxime Vacher La Grave et ça peut lui
donner confiance même pour un tour de
partie longue même si c'est du rapide ça
montre quand même un niveau de jeu qui
est
impressionnant
ouais alors Thierry Giro sur Youtube qui
dit tout le monde oublie carpov qui a
été champion du monde 75 à 85 et de 93 à
99 oui éit champion du monde il était
pas numéro mondial loin s'en fout il a
quand même perdu 5 matchs contre
Kasparov on le
rappelle un match interrompu et il y a
eu les 5 matchs 85
86 88 90 non il y a eu qure matchs
pardonf il y a eu C matchs avec le match
euh le match qui est interrompu à
5-3 mais
euh
mais
euh euh Kasparov dominé à cette époque
de 93 à 99 même s'il y a eu un problème
avec la FIDÉ bon on ne peut ne pas être
d'accord avec casparov tout ce qu'on
veut mais c'était quand même lui le
meilleur on peut on peut tourner le
problème dans tous les sens hein 1 dem 0
et demi nul signé on s'en doutait dans
cette finale de
tour nul signé entre Magnus Carlsen et
Maxime va pourquoi nul signer on va
regarder ça tout de suite ou c'est en
aller par là donc on allait donner un
pion par exemple on faisait ça t prend
à3 menace à 2 roi B1 et roi D5 et on
voit bien que les blancs peuvent pas
progresser si on bouge tour par là on
prend ce spion si on bouge à tour par là
on prend pion donc c'est nul
plein de fois orien TV j'ai joué
beaucoup beaucoup de fois contre Magnus
en partie officielle ou en partie al
partie amicale n'en parlons pas des
centaines de Blitz
ouais c'est vrai que dans 10 jours il va
jouer au Qatar mais ça c'est les
engagements pris de longue
date il aime quand il fait chaud Magnus
Carlsen il aime la
chaleur voilà mais je pense pas qu'il
reprendra ce genre d'engagement il va
jouer la Coupe d'Europe avec ses copains
voilà je pense que c'est genre de
tournoi qui jouera Coupe d'Europe ou
championnat d'Europe par équipe ou ou
olympiade des truc un petit peu où il y
a un truc social et il y a un truc pour
la Norvège aussi il aime beaucoup ses
compétitions par équipe que ça soit avec
son club ou avec son pays donc je pense
qu'il gardera plus ça plus que
ça je vois pas les av KZ il se passe
quoi et la cam de Magnus il il l'enlève
entre les parties
voilà ce qui se passe avec la cam de
Magnus tout simplement il a le droit
pourquoi il l'enlève moi je me suis
retrouvé
à c'est génial ce qui m'est arrivé je
vous raconte ça avant
de avant de faire la petite pause
pub je me préparais entre juste avant la
partie on a le droit de faire ce qu'on
veut quand même je me préparais et je me
préparais donc sur un autre ordi que j'
évidemment que j' j'enlève pendant le
pendant le match mais jeis de me
préparer avant avant que le match
commence c'est un quart d'heure j'étais
déjà dans le truc pour ils on tout
vérifier tout ça et donc je préparé sur
mon ordi et j'ai vu que la cam de
derrière moment j'ai vu que la cam de
derrière montrait dans le zoom ce que
j'étais en train de regarder et donc
effectivement c'était c'était quand même
embêtant vous
voyez donc c'est pour ça que enlever la
caméra peut de régler ce genre de
problème o on a le droit de se préparer
entre les parties hein c'est quand même
pas interdit non c'est pas du tout fini
pour ce soir bien sûr que non on
rappelle le braquet on RA le on rappelle
le bracket
euh le bracket c'est
euh la finale la grande finale entre
Magnus Carlsen et Maxime vaachz La Grave
1 et demi 0 et5i pour
mvl et c'est en quatre parties on le
rappelle et donc quatre parties
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire quatre parties ça veut dire
que si Maxime vach grave marque un sur
deux dans les deux prochaines il a gagné
le match s'il y a un dememi s'il y a
deux partout on a droit à armagenon avec
ce fameux système des enchères que
quelqu'un va expliquer dans le chat pour
moi parce que ça fait 50 fois que
j'explique depuis le départ mais voilà
vous l'aurez compris on l'aura peut-être
aujourd'hui et si la victoire de Maxime
dans ce match Magnus cararsen utilise sa
vie pour jouer un dernier match on a
droit à une défaite dans ce dans C dans
cette compétition Maxime l'a déjà eu
contre Magnus Carlsen mercredi
dernier mercredi il y a 2 jours et
donc et donc voilà donc Magnus l'aurait
éventuellement aujourd'hui ça sera en
deux parties le deuxème match on va voir
salut un salut amical j'ai vu un salut
amical sur YouTube à notre ami Yanis
salut à toi Yanis et voilà c'est un très
bon moment après ce salut amical pour
faire une
petite pause pub remerci secret
Lab les la chaise aings regardez-moi ça
c'est pas beau c'est presque un truc de
déco et euh Opera le meilleur navigateur
au monde depuis 2 semainesand depuis
qu'ils ont décidé de nous sponsoriser
sur ce ça reprend dans très exactement
je vais vous le
dire la partie elle est dans 6 minutes
donc je fais une petite pause ah je suis
en retard je parle trop
allez à tout de
[Musique]
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je suis de retour dans cette finale à
tente entre Magnus Carlsen et Maxime
Vachet la grave on va regarder le
braquet tout de suite et vous voyez que
mercredi Magnus Carlsen est venu à bout
l'armagueddon hein contre euh contre eux
il est venu à bout de mvl à
l'armagueddon simplement et donc maxime
vacheragrave a utilisé sa deuxième vie
et il est de retour il a nettoyé nepo il
a balayé NPO de la main gauche hier 2 à0
et ces deux joueurs n'ont pas d'ego dans
ce tournoi là en tout cas clairement il
domine très très largement et donc c'est
la revanche aujourd'hui en quatre
parties
si Maxime qui mène 1 demi 0 et demi
arrive à l'emporter il y aura un match
de deux parties pour les départager on
va voir c'est pas fini on nenterre
jamais le Norvégien parce que il est là
quand même il a prouvé à travers les
années quand même qui savait comment
revenir dans un match et vous voyez la
magnifique chaise de Magnus Carlsen
secret Lab avec je pense un logo échec
donc ça do être secret Lab champion de
chaise tour elle est belle cette chaise
on en veut et la partie va recommencer
dans une petite
minute pas de pub je suis vraiment
désolé mais là je suis euh je suis
complètement
obligé ça vous permet de faire les
petites pauses de 5
minutes sans le radon et oui
sisings c'est pas mal
avec c'est pas mal as quand même c'est
quand même abordable c'est des produits
qui sont pas du tout euh voyez hein moi
ça fait 4 ans que je l'ai 3 ans 3 4 ans
ah ben ça prend pas une ride he donc
c'est des produits à vie alors c'est
peut-être un
peu je sais pas combien ça coûte ça doit
coûter 250 € que je comme ça 200 € mais
en tout cas après c'est c'est
àe et ça vous permet de d'avoir d'être
sûr de vivre dans un environnement sain
c'est prouvé hein que effectivement
enfin on le sait hein si on respire
mal ben le cerveau tourne moins
vite alors non non non non non non il
est pas obligé de gagner 3 il est obligé
de gagner 2 et demi 1 et demi donc s'il
fait de nul c'est bon il all les noir
dans la prochaine la prochaine est hyper
importante voilà si Magnus ne gagne pas
la prochaine al si Magnus perd la
prochaine
ou là et ça joue cette ligne là
ok alors
là je la connais cette ligne un petit
peu en tout cas ça c'était c'est quelque
chose qui est quand même assez à la mode
ces derniers temps c'est un G accepté et
Magnus décide on va tourner che pour
mettre du côté de Maxime Maxime qui
c'est son dernier noir pour aujourd'hui
donc effectivement s'il fait nul c'est
une très bonne c'est c'est très bien
pour lui
mais parce qu'il aura les blancs dans la
dernière il mènera 2 donc au pire
Armageddon s' per les blancs ce qui est
quand même pas pas facile hein de battre
Maxim avec les noirs et s'il gagne c'est
gagné hein c'est gagné pour ce match là
ensuite il y a un autre match donc
desprend C4 et E4 je vous en parlais
c'est la ligne critique contre le GAM
accepté Magnus qui a peut-être profiter
pendant 10 minutes pendant les 10
minutes pour se préparer un petit peu
pour réviser ses notes et pourquoi pas
on a le droit E45 cavalier F3 fou B4
échec c'est vraiment une ligne très à la
mode C C3 cavalier F6 on
attaque4 mais les blancs font qu' prend
E5 si on fait qu' prend E4 il y a dama 4
échec qui est quand même une sacrée
mauvaise nouvelle sur k C6 on fait k
prend C6 ça ne va pas du tout pour les
Noirs donc on fait B5 et voilà on a
cette position très déséquilibrée avec
une majorité àel dame pour les Noirs
mais un centre très fort pour les blancs
qui est sous pression quand même on
menace qu' prend le 4 d'où le prochain
coup des blancs qui est de jouer F3 le
seul moyen à peu près descend de
protéger ce pion petit rock joué par les
Noirs A3 fou A5 fou E3 et cavalier fd7
joué par Maxime qui semblait ne pas se
souvenir parce qu'il y a pas mal de
théories donc on va voir k prend des7
joue à tempo par Magnus Carlsen qui
semble être dans sa
préparation cavalier prend k prend et
fou2 Maxime qui devra réviser hein pour
le s'il s' a un deuxième match
aujourd'hui il devra réviser sa ligne
il a probablement un ordinateur à côté
avec
euh avec les notes à noter que la
revanche n'est pas demain la revanche
est en suivant on peut être ensemble
jusqu'à minuit he attention ça peut
durer très
longtemps alors petit
rock et maintenant avec les Noirs va
falloir essayer de jouer C5 pour essayer
de challenger ce centre pour l'instant C
5 il a des5 donc ça n'irait pas ça
n'irait pas pour les pour les Noirs je
sais pas ce qu'on fait ici il fait fou
B7 alors fou B7 ça tape sur F3 4 mais
c'est certainement combiné avec l'idée
de jouer F7 F5 qui est logique pour
détruire cette
structure qu'est-ce qu'il a mon décor là
coconet plaî pas mon
décor je peux le changer tout de suite
je peux mettre en je peux mettre en are
fond
d'écran il me plaît bien mon décor alors
comment il va faire Magnus d C2 semble
normal d C2 on met les tours on lit les
tours on empêche F5 on va prendre sur F5
je sais pas c'est le prier coup qui me
viendrait ça semble assez
logique sur dame C2 qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire avec les Noirs certainement un
coup de dame pour remenacer F5 parce qu'
le fou en l'air pour faire F F quelque
chose comme ça avec les Blancs
ça joue ça
joue alors Magnus qui réfléchit quelles
sont les options en fait c'est ça c'est
la question qui
me qui m'intrigue il y a A4 qui est
toujours dans l'air pour A4 pour faire
pression sur le pion B et c'est sur B4
ça affaiblit ce pion et on peut reculer
reculer pour mieux sauter à 4 a été joué
par Magnus Carlsen c'était l'autre
option et oui on pose une grosse
question là on menace de prendre en B5
tout
simplement voilà c'est ça WLF super play
on va tous passer ça va être génial hein
ça va être génial
ah ben alors là ouais alors là par
contre euh là par contre mon cher ami
euh mon cher ami enfin non on est plus
ami là on va parler un peu mieux et ça
va être un ban def ça va être un band
def euh
voilà et oui ah quand je fais la police
dans le chat hein bandef pour notre ami
on peut rigoler tout ça mais bon
ouais donc on va passer un peut-être la
nuit ensemble ouais effectivement tous
ensemble alors
A4
C6
protège effectivement c'est trop tôt
trop tôt pour
les trop tôt pour
les pour les
casseroles A4 C6 et E5 jouer ah c'était
combiné ouais A4 C6 c'est le coup
logique mais ça enferme ce fou et donc
E5 on va menacer cavalier E4 et k D6
c'est pas mal du tout ça pour les
blancs c'est pas mal du tout j'aime
beaucoup ce que fait Magnus Carlsen dans
cette partie peut-être F4 F3 aussi qui
peut arriver les blancs qui qui menacent
qui menac quand même de prendre un gros
ascendant
là je vois pas trop comment on fait avec
les Noirs si vous avez des
idées c'est bienvenu parce que là c'est
compliqué
tour
8 ok mais j'aime pas du
tout bon ben après il a pris un peu de
temps tour8 qu'est-ce qui se passe sur
cavalier E4 on a l'impression que ça
vient dans le dans le viseur
là cavalier4 l'air fort quand même
cavalier4 D6 donc s'organiser un coup de
fou mais alors c'est pas c'est pas un
truc d'attaque si vous voyz ce que je
veux dire pere même F5 ici la dame va
devoir aller sur une case où elle a pas
envie d'aller bref c'est l'enfer et je
vois pas la contreindication F4 aussi me
tend très bien pour faire fou F3 lae
l'air d'accord fou F3 et met la pression
sur cette grande diagonal avec ce fou
qui est enfermé par son propre pion
c'est pas terrible tout
ça
c'est pas terrible tout ça c'est C c'est
C des C
hein et cavalier E4 C5 et a C D6 et on
va laisser des plumes parce que on
attaque le fou B7 et la tour
8 c'est ça essayz
de il a du il y a du bruit mais là c'est
en face cette fois j'ai la fenêtre
ouverte il on commmence à faire chaud à
Paris là le bruit s'il y a du bruit ça
vient en face ça vient pas d'ici tour 8
j'aime pas du
tout mais Magnus qui réfléchit qui doit
hésiter entre F4 et cavalier E4
franchement cavalier E4 est hyper
tentant fou C7 et un coup comme même
dame C2 vous voyez menace k G5 des
choses comme ça ou fou
G5 c'est qu même pas dingue pour les
Noirs tout
ça alors on va voir ce que va nous faire
ce que nous concocte Magnus Carlsen mais
c'est plutôt bon pour Maxime he qui
réfléchisse au temps
clairement F4 et F4 et ouais F4 est joué
F4 est joué F4 est archi tentant
cavalier4 av l'air pas mal aussi
j'aurais préféré cavalier4 pour être
tout à fait honnête avec vous mais
après c'est le Go c'est c'est c'est
Magnus Carlsen qui candidate êre le GO
pour faire F
F3 F F3 peut arriver va arriver très
certainement on a un très fort centre on
a réussi à pousser ses pions c'est un
cauchemar pour Maxime vachagrave qui a
une position non seulement objectivement
inférieur mais très très dur à jouer où
il peut se faire rouleau compressé assez
rapidement avec des F5 F6 qui peuvent
arriver aussi s'il survit cette partie
ça sera
beau parce que franchement l'ouverture
est complètement ratée il s'est pas
souvenuin Maxime assez clairement il
s'est pas venu de sa prep normalement
Magnus fait pas ce genre de chose hein
de jouer euh les variantes principales
comme ça mais ça peut arriver aussi
c'est la c'est la force de
Magnus qui sa'est très bien le roi de la
psychologie ça je l'ai souvent dit
souvent vécu c'est le c'est le roi de la
psychologie Magnus
cararsen c'est j'ai déjà vu il m'a déjà
dit hein euh il m'a déjà dit qu'il avait
changé d'ouverture je lui demande
pourquoi il a pas joué ce qu'on a
préparé il a changé d'ouverture parce
qu'il a vu son adversaire il a senti
qu'il était pas
qui était pas en son état
normal je ve dire avant la partie quoi
on lui sert la main en regardant 30
secondes sans le regarder en plus il a
senti un truc et il avait raison il
avait gagné assez facilement donc ça
arrive ça arrive ce genre de chose donc
Magnus qui croit qui croit au bon coup
et à la psychologie la différence de
fich c'est les
deux F5
F5 ouais pour empêcher cavalier E4 et
bien oui alors effectivement on dirait
F5 c'est toujours trop tôt les pièces
noires sont un peu par là mais en même
temps on avait pas de solution à lui
proposer à Maxime il il en propose une
propose une évidemment on peut pas
prendre un passant il le fou en prise
mais on peut imaginer qu'un coup comme
dame C2 puisse faire mal attaque ici sur
G6 on
peut presque tenté d'envoyer
G4 ici peut-être G4 même G4 lae lae est
contente après G4 rendez compte mais
même faut F3 on peut jouer gentimen hein
après les Noirs vont essayer de faire
quelque chose comme ça ou cavalier F8
cavalier E6 mais F4 F5 G4 àair fort
peut-être dame C2 d'abord petit coup de
préparation et ensuite
G4 on va voir mais F5 pas mal j'aime
bien F5 en fait dans les circonstances
hein de la partie évidemment je trouve
que F5 justement évite ces histoires de
rouleau compresseur à l' droit avec F 4
F5 éventuellement E6 ou F6 ce genre de
chose donc on peut faire cavalier F8
cavalier E6 et fou B6 au moins on a un
plan on va voir ce que va faire euh
Magnus Carlsen ouais il a appris ce jeu
psychologique gr grâce à casparov
surtout il appris beaucoup des joueurs
qui jou à l'époque grâce à casparov
notamment
deand de il écoutit beaucoup Kasparov
surtout pour joueram et compagnie
l'ancienne génération la première
génération qu'il a battu avant de jouer
mvl carwana les autres joueurs que
Kasparov n'a jamais joué donc là c'est
différent
carwana
Aronian
mvl qui sont quand même beaucoup
beaucoup plus jeunes que Kasparov ça
fait quoi ça fait quasiment
30 c'est une grosse génération
d'éc nous sommes tous à la recherche du
bon coup tout à fait maintenant qu'on a
l'idé est- qu'on commence par F3 ou pas
c'est ça la
question
7 on l'a connu jouant plus vite
Maxime qui a pas une belle position il
le sait très bien Maxime il est pas fou
vous inquiétez pas pour lui il sait
qu'il est pas il a raté son ouverture il
joue assez vite et il attend des des
meilleurs
jours cavalier f86 le problème c'est que
F4 cavalier F8 ça donnit F5 c'est le
problème il pas de cavalier
auss c'est le défaut et il a joué D4
D5 du scars un coup j' pas du tout
envisagé et
ben alors quel est
l'idée sur pion prend D5 il veut faire
pion prend B5 je suppose ou
pas où
ça peut-être ça simplement ah non ça il
y a ça ok Etam prend des5 ok donc puis
on prend des5 puis on prend B5 ah sur
fou prend C3 il a on prend un 6
intermédiaire ça marche ça non ça ne
marche pas ça ne marche pas du
tout on a les tourbéant encore mais ça
paraît très
artificiel je sais pas même ça ça ça on
ail un pion pour pas
grand-chose donc quelle est l'idée puion
on
prend puis on prend peut-être prend C3 B
prend C3 puis on prend
et là ch l' de dire que ça ne va pas du
tout pour les
Noirs ça me saute pas aux
yeux mais je rate quelque chose je vais
tricher alerte triche prend 8 F prend 8
ah ouais après il fait G4 simplement et
fout des4 il massacre les drit
wou son idée c'est énorme des 4 6 F5 et
fini ça joue fort ça joue très
fort attention peut pas tolérer ce pion
D6 finir la partie donc faut faire
quelque chose avec les Noirs ici
qu'est-ce qu' dit l'ordinateur il dit
fou B6 meilleur
couput
avir prend prend mais on est dans la
sauce quand
même
ouais admettons pion prend cavalier
prend et il se défend comme ça
ok ok ok ok F B6 faut y
penser honnêtement ça échapperait à mon
radar et c'est jouer F prend C3 et oui
trop
dur est-ce que Magnus a vraiment compris
ce truc là s'il a s'il fait appr prend à
prend t prend 8 prend 8 G4 bon ben
chapeau mais bon il met pas tellement il
il passe tellement ça vie à me
surprendre que je serais je suis même
plus surpris je suis surpris de pas être
surpris en fait ouais le pic de Magnus
c'est 2019 où il a eu il a eu il a
bénéficié
de de aussi la prépa qui avait été très
très sérieuse peut-être notre prépa la
plus aboutie ça s'est pas vu pendant le
match ça s'est vu avec les Noirs mais
pas avec les blancs de match de 2018
contre carwana où prpA extrêmement
sérieuse qui s'est vu en 2019 où il a il
a montré toutes les idées et il a eu des
très belles positions grâce à
ça alors
ouais si c'est son non parce que G4 on
on
l'avait on l'avait quand même vu venir
avec Dame C2 G6 G4 moi je proposais
depuis tout à
l'heure donc G4 est dans l'esprit
clairement et là c'est vrai que ça ferme
on a on a un moyen très clair de fermer
la grande diagonale avec fou des4 alors
peut-être qu'on peut même d'ailleurs on
va voir hein ce que ça donne t prend fou
prend admettons fou des4 et G4 ensuite
pour être sûr de pas se prendre un D4
mais bon faut avouer que après G4 D4
fait pas non plus hyper peur il y a dame
prend d prend on menace tour D1 la dame
est pas encore là et puis de toute façon
même si si elle arrive là il y aura fou
F3 donc c'est pas
extraordinaire je pense qu'il va je
pense que c'est ça son idée
bon ou alors je
surestime j'ai 4 tout de suite
aussi est-ce que j'ai 4 tout de suite
quelle est la différence h j'ai 4 tout
de suite j'aime bien aussi puis on prend
et la ligne de l'ordi mais j'ai 4 tout
de suite garde la tenstion pourquoi pas
qu'est-ce qu'on perd à faire
ça je pense que c'est pas
mal ouais ouais désolé j'essaie de voir
les deux chat je réponds en priorité au
chat de
twitch je suis désolé pour nos amis de
YouTube qui sont aussi nombreux he que
nos amis de de twitch mais bon on peut
pas faire tous les chats en même temps
sinon on se comprend plus mais n'hésitez
pas j'en profite pour ceux qui nous
regardent sur twitch ou YouTube à vous
abonner aux chaînes de chesscom damc de
jouer de chess 24 tout ce que vous
voulez mais abonnez-vous mettez un petit
pouce ça nous fait ça nous aide
et ça n permet d'avoir un retour donc
allez-y le pouce bleu pour avoir la
notif quand on est en live et un pouce
bleu pour dire que vous avez aimé si
vousz si vous aimez
bien C2 attaque le
pion G6 c'est délicat quand même G6
parce que voyez on a un fot cas noir
donc ça peut faire très mal ces
histoires mais comment on
fait tour F8 sinon mais tour F8 laisse
un peu le champ libre au pion
ouais Magnus qui quand même qui a joué
avec 356 contre 727 pour
mvl grosse réflexion quand même de de
Magnus
Carlsen Jean-Michel malutant
ouais ouais 3 minutes de retard une très
belle position quand même heureusement
pour lui G4 pas trouvé moi je pensais
vraiment qu'il allait le faire
honnêtement G6
jouer il croit vraiment pas à G4 et j'ai
qu jouer et c'était meilleur coup
d'avant pourquoi c'était meilleur en
coup
d'avant parce que là d'après
la la variante c'est D4 maintenant et
fouprend on peut pas reprendre de la
dame on redonne ce pion puis on prend
fouprend et là y a K C5 ah ouais c'est
la différence de par la dame en D1 et
sur F prend C5 on a dame D5 menace des
choses méchantes par là menace de
récupérer le meilleur coup c'est F F3 en
fait dame prend C5 et on est
complètement ok alors va-t-il le jouer
j'enlève la ligne d'ordi parce que sinon
je vais vous donner que des lges
d'ordi il faut jouer puis on prend prend
et D4 ah ça c'est un truc trouvable pour
Maxime
clairement si on aime pas on met un
pouce en bas puis surtout si vous aimez
pas vous regardez vous regardez pas quoi
c'est ça aussi l'idée en fait faut se
faire plaisir dans la vie faut pas
oublier ça et5 jouer oui sans prendre en
G4 bien vu par Maxime mais quelle forme
Maxime alors c'est moins fort
apparemment certainement à cause de pion
prend
F5 ah c'est dommage d'avoir vu l'idée
mais deavoir fait maessens et oui
qu'est-ce qu'il fait sur P F5 Maxime k
B3 tour D1
ah ben alors ben alors Maxime il voit
l'idée de la joue dans le mauvais
ordre ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même assez assez
étonnant la tête de Maxim G4 il croyait
pas ou il croyait pas G4 ou il a fait
d'ailleurs des4 des4 à tempo sacré
Maxime qui croit en son fou de de ce
blanche mais là il s'est un peu
précipité c'est
dommage c'est age ah ouais mais
bon ce qui reste en aimant pas le Chud
juste pour le critiquer je l'ai plain
quand même
franchement c'est dommage quoi c'est une
vie pas très marrante
quoi il va prendre bien sûr qu'il va
prendre 2 40 Magnus Carlsen qui joue
avec le feu quand
même il joue avec le feu je vois pas ce
qu'il a vu sur P F5 par contre c'est ça
qui qui me qui m'interroge c'est la
question qui m'interroge comment on dit
k D3 Mo je fais F6 hein ah ouais on
rigole pas on rigole pas là
euh dame D5 il a toujours fou F3 et puis
attention c'est des pions ils sont
proches du roi enfin vous voyez he c'est
de pion passé lié peut faire E6 et F7
hein Magnus va jouer puis on prend il
joue puis on prend B 5 d'abord ça cré
sacrée Magnus étonnant étonnant cette
décision
alors qu'est-ce que ça change est-ce
qu'on a un fou4 inter ah non fou4 il f
prend C qu échecs ou là là oui donc pu
on prend menace F prend C4 dame D5 il
fou F3 je crois que ça change absolument
rien B3 il f prend C4
abandon donc puis on prend B5
intermédiaire
jolie alors puis on prend on prend on
prend pas de la dame évidemment parce
qu'on perd cette astuce avec Dame D5 on
prend du Fou et ensuite il veut prendre
ici
c'est ça son idée sans sans donner kib3
ça c'est tellement lui de rien donner
aucun contrejeu et oui il adore ça
Magnus
Carlsen attends est OK pour CSEN 230
oui oui oui oui oui
oui certes
ah il veut faire ça tour prend
non j'ai prends5 4 ça marche pas du
tout 4 ça marche pas du tout parce que
là je fais un coup de dame n'importe où
dame calier va être obligé de bouger et
ensuite je vais pousser les pions ça ne
va pas à mon
avis3 jouer ok mais F6 F6 c'est cher
c'est de pass li c'est
trop c'est beaucoup trop
là bon F6 jou et oui et oui c'est trop
facile
terminé c'est objectivement terminé pour
pour mvl il y a pas y a pas photo
là il est cuit Maxime va la grave dans
cette partie
ouais non non non c'est dur à regarder
même c'est très dur à
regarder il y avait le cavalier en prise
c'est dommage c'est dommage ce F 4
marche pas peut-être qu'il a une
hallucination
moi je suis pour je suis pour le
spectacle encore cette
question tu es pour qui est-ce qu'on a
besoin d'être pour quelqu'un pour garder
un B match d'échec je crois pas je suis
content quoi qu'il arrive c'est pas
c'est pas beau quand même c'est pas beau
cette vie là
voilà si un beau match je suis
content et un beau vainqueur le
vainqueur le méritera c'est certain
allez Maxime là qui va chercher la
dernière peau de banane je la vois pas
perso mais la bonne
nouvelle
c'est que
Maxime est meilleur que moi pour ça pour
trouver des pot de banane donc il va
probablement poser une dernière pot de
banane
l'UR pour Magnus nous dit au chat mais
il est payé pour dire allez Maxime quel
psychologue et comme j'adore être payé
je vais le dire allez Maxime
voilà alors dame des7 jouer ah c'est pas
mal ça ça me plaît bien on va
chatouiller par
là on va chatouiller par
là E pas mal est-ce que je fais al moi
je Seris hyper tenté de faire F F3 parce
que je vous avouerai que ça ça
m'angoisse ce truc mais c'est pas
terrible du tout ah c'est extraordinaire
non mais je je viens de voir F pr F3
tour pr F3 dam
G4 et sur dame G2 dame prend G2 roi
prend G2 cavalier1 ah non d dame G4 il a
tour G3 je raconte n'importe quoi je
suis en tilt intégral dame G4 tour G3 et
dame prend F4 et les blanc reste mieux
alors c'est quoi le coup sur dame D7
c'était quoi la la
combine ah je vais la regarder F pr F3
oh là fourchette je rate des fourchettes
à un coup bah dis donc bah dis donc mais
oui bien sûr que j'avais vu en plus un
coup plus tard donc c'était pas bon du
tout évidemment Magnus Carlsen il rigole
pas il fait dame D1 et B4 joué par
Maxime qui essaie
vraiment de faire de son mieux pour
compliquer les choses mais fou G4 joué
par Magnus Caren si va sur la grande
diagonale on revient avec le fou et si
on va pas sur la grande diagonale on va
se prendre E6 et attention
ouais va aller en tête peut-être pas
pour longtemps là dame D5 F F3 ouais
mais il é obligé de faire ça et
d'échanger les fous et dame D7 le coup
du
retour comment on fait ici avec les
Blancs pour en terminer il fait faut
prend un 8 t prend un
8 et maintenant faut mettre
en marche c'estes pions alors est-ce
qu'on joue dame 2 est-ce qu'on joue dame
F3 gag un temps sur la tour ça l'air pas
mal quandmeacer du F5 après f56 F7 et on
pousse tout en même
temps F3 attaque la tour là c'est
compliqué pour les noirs
ouais la jauge remonte bof
bof bof bof Magnus qui gère pas mal
quand même cette conversion parce que F5
va être quand même va faire très mal on
va pas se mentir on va pas se mentir on
une dernière partie
explosive après c'est pas fini
ah je me fais engueuler dans le chat
parce que je vois pas les les trucs
c'est pas facile hein les fourchettes
mes spécialistes pour se prendre les
pots de banane oui c'est vrai oh là en
championnat du monde de Blitz je vais
peut-être y retourner cette année ti on
va peut-être se chauffer mais je suis
énervé je suis comme un fou après 5
rondes je suis déjà je me suis pris tous
les pièges du monde
entier je suis
en puis plus vous vous énervez plus vous
jouez mal quoi et plus vous prenez de
piège enfin bon c'est un cercle vicieux
et puis la nuit on dort pas puis le
lendemain hop c'est reparti pour un tour
c'est l'enfer
tour 8 pour empêcher F5 ah mais pas
vraiment nous dit Magnus Carlsen
pourquoi pourquoi ça empêchait pas F5
c'était quoi l'astuce F prend tour prend
et puis on prend G6 et sur H prend G6 il
y avait F7 suite dame a 8 c'était
complètement terminé il fait P prend F5
Maxime va chez La Grave il sent il
défend très très bien j'adore comment il
défend de manière active sur casse
blanche il va nous faire un roi volant
sur dame G3 il nous fait un roi volant
j'ai l'impression oh parce que ro H8
c'est côté cimetière quand même F7
damepr F7 E6 terminado mais damepr F5
joué par Magnus Carlsen est-ce que c'est
bien joué et dame pr on prend menace F7
mais roi F7 va venir le roi blour le
fameux on va jouer puis on prend B4 avec
les Blancs on est quand même
probablement complètement gagnant avec
les Blancs k prend B4 tour G5 tour G7 va
arriver non ro F2 il vient leoi il garde
ses pions passés liés c'est ça le c'est
ça la clé de la position mais c'est pas
bon d'après la Jae il y a un truc truc
là pour les Noirs alors peut-être alors
peut-être c'est quoi le truc pour les
Noirs je le vois pas le truc pour les
Noirs c'est tour C8 menace de pousser et
sur fou C3 on fait c D5 ah mais la jauge
qui change d'Ave al peut-être pas tour
C8 tour H5 quand même elle dit la jauge
et tour prend H7 ouais c'est encore
difficile he pour pour Maxime c'est
clair tour C8 joué et tour G5 joué par
Magnus Carlsen pour faire tour G7 échec
le bon coup d'après lae mais alors allez
savoir pourquoi c'est très très dur D5
ah c'est pour empêcher tour G7 tour 7 ok
ça a du sens alors c'est trouvable5 le
bon coup ici pour Maxime tour
g76 quelle partie quelle partie encore
que les de joueurs nous font tour G7
c'est joué ou pas est-ce que c'est joué
non c'est pas joué ah c'est joué 6
d'abord tour5 ça ne change rien et
maintenant surour pr H7 C3 et on a du
jeu on a les Chan sortir mais c'est pas
fait
c'est pas fait c'est pas fait du tout
mais t prend H7 Maxime qui est pas loin
de la sauver C F7 C2 fou B2 et là il y a
K C3 apparemment qui sauve la qui sauve
la boutique mais alors allez le trouver
ce truc tour à 7 C3 tour à 6 échec joué
par Magnus Carlsen ro F5 F7 et sur C2
qu'est-ce qu'il veut il veut tour C6 sur
C2 40 secondes pour les deux joueurs oh
là là c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est
bouillantissime qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire ici je vois plus rien il faut
faire c de quand même tour C tour C6
tour F8 tour prend C2 et l'ordinateur il
dit que ça fait nul ça
facile c'estc le roi est actif les
pièces noires sont actives C de fou B2
joué par Magnus Carlsen on peut pas
faire dam fou prend et on fait dam
nous-même il veut faire aussi son
prochain coup je suppose oh là là il il
faut faire tour F8 c'est le meilleur
coup ici et sur E 6 K C7 va-t-il le voir
tour F8 jouer quelle défense quelle
défense de Maxime incroyable il était
complètement foutu je l'avais quasiment
déjà enterré dans cette partie en tout
cas et bien il monte des ressources de
défense école française de la souffrance
sacré
Maxime il s'en sort il est
incroyable et Magnus qui a plus que 13
secondes et qui regarde le désastre ça
va faire nul 67 va être joué évidemment
et ouais ça fait une mou ça fait une mou
et il devra l'emporter avec les Noirs
dans la dernière Magnus car pour
s'offriron
ouais là c'est sûr que ça fait nul ça va
même pas la jouer proposition de nul
accepter c'est faire pour les deux
joueurs ouais ça fait voyez Maxime il
est pas DUP il sait très bien qu'il l'
écha pbelle he dans celle-là oh le roi
de la peau de banane le roi du menacer
de menacer pour menacer c'était un petit
peu le tournant ce dame des7 hein vous
avez vu ça ah ah moi je me serais
complètement découragé hein à ce
moment-là c'est énorme c'est euh voilà
ce ce ce moment-là il a raté son
ouverture complètement et là il fait
dame des7 il menace rien mais il menace
de menacer il nous l'avait expliqué en
live déjà
Maxime c'est énorme énorme grosse
défense alors qu'est-ce qu'il a raté
comme comme gros gain la F5 apparemment
était déjà complètement gagnant mais bon
c'est pas évident Dam est pas mal et en
fait Magnus a bien joué jusque là la F5
c'est très bien joué puis on prend il
fallait jouer dame G3 dame G3 était très
fort et sur ro7
ou tour le coup le coup de l'autre côté
et sur tour G8 qu'est-ce qui se passait
E6
d prend E6 ça fallait encore bien
calculer he tour à 7 et c'est que si si
on va sur la 8e il y avait échec encore
donc ça n'allait
pas et donc après dame prend F7 superbe
défense puis on prend B4 bien joué qui
prend B4 faait faire tour G5 direct il a
ramené son roi vers le centre qui a un
peu le coup automatique mais tour G5
était beaucoup plus fort sachant que
tour G8 est pas vraiment possible parce
qu'il a E6 euh roi E6 et maintenant tour
G7 qui
3 et roi F1 ici et apparemment ça gagné
quand même pourquoi prend 5 fou prend
roi prend et tour 7
ok bravo Maxime vachz la grave qui
l'emporte dans cette 3oè partie du match
al effectivement c'est pas terminé
mais Magnus Carlsen pour s'offrir un
Armagedon dans ce match là sera obligé
de
l'emporter si il ne gagne gagne pas dans
la 4e on a droit à deux parties en plus
pour savoir qui c'est qui est le grand
vainqueur il y aura eu un partout dans
leur match et donc on met un partout
balle au centre et on repart à zéro pour
un match en deux
parties ce soir maintenant juste après
le match mais quel quel combat il nous
offre vraiment il est
pas c'est c'est tout sauf tout sauf des
vent c'est magnifique magnifique Maxime
qui arrive à à dominer la Magnus he dans
ces trois premières parties clairement
prochaine partie je vais vous dire j'ai
mon col zoom j'ai le j'ai les mêmes
infos que les joueurs c'est pas beau ça
prochaine partie dans très exactement 7
minutes ce qui me laisse
évidemment le temps habituel
pour souffler et vous laissz souffler et
me laissz souffler et laisser souffler
les joueurs c'est mérité surtout pour
les joueurs c'est quand même pour eux
que c'est le plus dur et en vous
proposant une petite chess Rama je sais
pas ce que c'est comme pub mais bon en
tout cas on la met c'est
obligatoire voilà c'est obligatoire et
regardez ce que c'est ce chess Rama vous
me
raconterez à tout de suite prochaine
partie dans 7
minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de retour pour cette dernière partie du
l'éventuel premier match on sait pas si
Maxime Vacher La Grave
continue son sa course en tête en tout
cas dans ce match il mène 21 dans ce
cette grande finale et il pourrait s'il
perd pas la prochaine il a gagné le
premier match mais Magnus Carlsen
utiliserait sa
vie parce que on a le droit à on a le
droit de perdre une fois dans ce dans ce
tournoi
Maxime grave s incliné mercredi contre
Magnus Carlsen et donc ça pourrait être
la revanche et ensuite on aurait deux
parties ça se jouera en deux parties la
très très grande
finale de parties donc allerretour avec
un éventuel Armagedon merci dans le chat
twitch été très bien expliqué par chess
and play learmagedon les deux joueurs
font une enchère secrète de temps pour
les Noirs celui qui a fait l'enchère à
plus basse joue les Noirs les Blancs
impérativement gagneré en 15 minutes et
donc on peut faire de 0 à 15 l'enchè
voilà c'est simple que ça et je vais on
voit des choses qu'on ne devrait pas
voir Magnus Carlsen est revenu et voyz
les deux magnifiques chais secret Lab
mais vous en voyez trois en fait parce
qu'il a deux chez
Magnus c'est le privilège des des
champion du
monde voilà c'est ça juste après on va
voir en tout cas si Maxime ne perd pas
cette partie il a pas d'armagedon à
jouer s'il perd il a les blancs il a les
blanc dans la dernière donc c'est quand
même un sacré avantage sil perd il a un
Armagedon pour ce premier match mais il
y a pas de raison il y a honnêtement
objectivement pas de raison qu'il perd
ce premier match tellement il joue bien
il défend bien même quand il est en
difficulté il se défend bien alors là
plus de berlinoise pour la dernière
partie ça c'est certain on va avoir une
Sicilienne ou quelque chose comme
ça de la part
de de Magnus quoi exactement j'en sais
absolument
rien mais ça va être ça va être très
chaud et ça devrait
commencer
euh c'est maintenant normalement à ma à
mon horloge c'est
maintenant alors à mon c'est maintenant
et une carocane joué par Magnus
Carlsen je l'avais dit pas de pas de pas
de berlinoise après je pensis plutôt une
Sicilienne mais effectivement la Caran
fait s ce qu'il avait utilisé dans son
Armon face à face à
Maxime et
E5 la d'avance qui est la plus populaire
en ce moment
F F5 mais qui donne des chances aussi au
noir cavalier F3 plus mou que ce qu'il
avait fait dans la magedon où il était
obligé de gagner il avait joué avec H4
Maxime va chez La Grave H4 H5 C4 6 mais
ça avait pas du tout marché donc il a dû
il a dû préparer quelque chose fou 2 et
A5 joué par Magnus Carlsen ok A5 c'est
pour prendre de l'espace à à l' dame
petit rock et
A4 ouais clairement on prend l'espace et
on voit comment les les blancs se
développent le centre est fermé donc on
peut se permettre de ce genre de choses
avec les Noirs euh attention hein faites
pas ça à la maison ça peut mal se passer
mais Magnus clairement peut se permettre
ce genre de de
pousser
intéressant intéressant ah le second
match ouais
en et il joue ces qu hein il essaie de
punir tout de suite mais il donne la
case D5 au cavalier Magnus qui joue à
tempo et il joue k D7 ouais on peut
aussi l'avoir comme ça AC B6 qui D5
intéressant positionition de style bon
Magnus qui a une position tout à
fait quand on est en en obligation de
gagner c'est exactement le genre de
position qu'on veut c'est-à-dire
position archi déséquilibré donc mais il
sait faire évidemment Magnus
Carlsen il a eu déjà ce genre de
situation donc il sa'est faire créer le
déséquilibre fou de joué par Maxime et
je suppose qu'on va
soit mettre l'autre cavalier ici soit
jouer à 3 à un moment faut faire
attention he on peut pas faire c D5 tout
de suite il y a C prend à 4 donc petit
problème sur le pion
a pour l'instant c'est pour ça que je
voulais le pousser ou alors mettre
l'autre cavalier en D5 attention à pas
se faire chauffer le fou peut-être
cavalier 7 il y a peut-être cavalier H4
qui est intéressant pour attaquer le le
fou de casse blanche et le prendre
même on na jamais vraiment envie de le
donner ce fou il me semble après je suis
pas un expert de
de carokan à quel point on est embêté de
donner ce fou j'en sais rien mais pas
trop apparemment il a joué ko 7 Magnus
Carlsen donc sur cavalier H4 je pense
qu'il veut faire certainement fou G6 et
après qu' prend G6 reprend du pion h et
c'est vrai que ça peut donner du jeu
aussi au noir on va voir ce que va faire
Maxime est-ce qu'il estime que ça vaut
de tempo oui il estime que ce fou vaut
de tempo c'est plutôt aussi mon mon avis
au au fining mais bon euh c'est pas
évident on va voir on va voir ce que
fait Magnus est-ce qu'il va jouer ce ce
fou G6
euh ce fou G6 je crois qu'on peut pas
tout à fait laisser faire un truc comme
ça c'est pas c'est pas beau ça puis ça
permettrait peut-être des E6 éventuels
j'aime pas quoi
que il fait H6 Magnus ok alors là bon
ben 6 prend F5 on veut faire fou H7 et
on aura perdu du temps avec ce cavalier
H4 donc on prend prend ah oui son idée
c'est avec le cavalier j'attaque le pion
d il fait fou3 Maxime et A3 est joué
très
vite hyper intéressant qu'est-ce que je
vous dise passionnant ce début de partie
avec des enjeux positionnels très fort
si on joue pu on prend un 3 on a activé
la la tour si on joue B3 je suppose
qu'il aura du Fou B4 c'est un peu
embêtant parce que on va mettre
certainement l'autre cavalier en D5
mettre la pression sur ce fou en E3 et à
3 il joue tour B1 très vite waouh waouh
waouh waouh et ils jouent sur Laur
planète là c'est des grosses décisions à
chaque coup euh pas évidente
hein
donc comment fait-on est-ce qu'il va
nous laisser le temps de
réfléchir t bien c'est c'est logique
hein parce que on prend pas oui bien sûr
on est prêt à échanger les les pions
mais à nos conditions et c'est vrai
quand on a tour en B1 on attaque le K B6
il a le pion B7 derrière euh c'est chaud
c'est chaud pour les pour les
Noirs je sais pas comment faire
honnêtement pas évident pas évident pour
les
Noirs alors la réponse
F 7
ok ok plus de fou B4 F B4 mainant se
mette se metteit dans le dans
l'ouverture de la colonne qui pouvait ça
pouit jouer des tours on p jouer sur F
B4 par exemple d B3 je sais pas d B3 un
truc comme ça c'estra que ça pouvait
voyez pr C3 pr C3 on voit tout de suite
à quoi ça sert tout ça et il fait F il
décide de calmer le jeu et de dire à
Maxime tu veux que je prends deux et ben
non c'est toi qui prendra à 3 ça peut
durer longtemps hein parce qu'ils sont
têtus les deux hein euh ils sont ils
sont teigneux comme tout hein
donc ça va pas craquer hein on peut
avoir ce pion A3 et B2 pendant 10 coups
hein moi je vous le dis fout des trois
jouet voyez ah on va les compter les
coups à partir de A3 au 13e coup moi je
pense que jusqu'au c'est favoris que
jusqu'au 20e coup il y a encore les
pions A3 et B2 personne va vouloir
prendre alors fou D3 on menacee de
prendre un F5
ou pas c'est toujours la question petit
rock faut prend F5 puis on prend F5
est-ce que c'est
grave peut-être peut-être un coup
de je sais pas peut-être dame C2 ou dame
D3 ou dame F3 dame D3 dame
D7 je sais pas si c'est grave alors
est-ce qu'on a envie de prendre ici je
crois pas ça R force le centre des
blancs j'aime pas trop ça ouvre des
perspectives pour l'attaque à l'ilroi
peut-être dame G4 dame4 ce genre de
chos F cou reposé favorise le camp qui
attaque faut pas
oublier c'est complexe vous voyez on a
joué à peine 15 coups et la position est
volcanique vraiment en ébullition là il
y a des il y a des prises possibles de
partout des Chang structure très très
intéressant ah non il y a pason là y a
deux partout Magic blunder si Magnus si
et seulement si Magnus car doit
absolument l'emporter s'il l'emporte pas
y a pas y a pas d'armagon
pardon ça baille un peu chez
Maxime
possible dur à gérer ces matchs tard le
soir on sait pas trop comment organiser
la journée on est pas habitué en fait
les joueurs d'échec les parties sont
plutôt à 14 15h donc quand ces matchs
sont à 18h on sait jamais trop quoi
faire il a pris un E3 Magnus donc ça
peut arriver que on soit un peu fatigué
mais bon faut être là jusqu'à minuit
Maxime non ça sera pas minuit parce que
les parties vont vite là donc bon au
maximum ça se terminera à
23h prend le 3 puis on prend le 3 et
petit rock il a fait ce truc là qui
donne de l'attaque mais après tout comme
on joue pour tous les résultats
c'est-à-dire que on a pas peur de perdre
perdre nul c'est la même chose donc on
est prêt à prendre des risques et
laisser de
l'attaque au
blanc après attention à pas laisser des
perpètes au blanc parce que les blancs
vont vont prendre les
perpètes vous voyez un ce fou he qui
peut se régaler un jour ou l'autre voyez
c'estes pions peut-être c'est 5 va
arriver aussi et là ça semble tous les
ingrédients sont là pour lancer une
attaque genre un truc cavalier E4
cavalier
F6 qu cavalier E4 il auras CER D5 je
pense contrôle la case F6
attaque3
complexe comment on fait peut-être dame
B3 aussi le petit coup sûr dame B3 me
plaît
bien par mene d'attaquer on menasse de
liquider un petit peu quoi que faut se
méfier de fou G5 G5 est quand même pose
une vraie question la j pas
d'accord petit fou C de jouer
intéressant menace dame
D3 clair intention d'attaquer et oui il
a raison Maxime parce que
c'est
c'est c'est l'idée du de la position
la revanche serait juste
après donc on a un vainqueur ce soir on
a un vainqueur un deè le vainqueur sera
ici le deè sera ici c'est Magnus
et mvl qui se Batt pour les deux
premières places de cette dernière étape
du champion chour avant la grande finale
de Toronto du 9 au 16 décembre c'est
bien possible que Maxime joue sa Calif
sur ce match parce que ça pas très bien
marché la saison du championour pour
et on le regrette parce que franchement
quand on voit le potentiel il aurait pu
il aurait pu virer en tête
ou au coup d' coup avec
Magnus est-ce que Magnus est sympa dans
la vie c'est une
crème c'est une crème il est
gentil il a cette
[Musique]
grande comment dire il a ce truc de de
de de en tout
cas les relations sont faussé forcément
vu que je fais partie en je suis employé
par lui j'été employé par lui pendant 10
ans
donc le truc c'est que il a c'est un
vrai naturel c'est un leader naturel
voilà il y a cette qualité là c'est
qu'il ne s'est jamais plein ni en public
ni en privé de de mon travail de travail
de qui que ce soit c'est très bien que
tout le monde fait de son
mieux et donc même sil sait que c'est
pas parfait tout le temps et bien il se
plaint ni en privé ni en public et ça
c'est quand même il valorise il valorise
son équipe et ça c'est quand même euh
très agréable surtout quand on donne le
meilleur de nous-même alors fou G5
attaque le
pion dame des3 menace le petit échec et
mat et G si ça a été vu par Magnus
Carlsen bravo Magnus bon pied bon
œil et maintenant comment on fait pour
qu'on continuer alors on peut envoyer la
cavalerie par cavalier E4 on peut aussi
essayer d'envoyer comme ça G3 pour faire
H4 mais sur G3 je pense qu'on va jouer
H5 et sur H4 on fait fau H6
gentiment alors maintenant faut regarder
toujours il y a des tour prend F7 hein
qui traînent là ça doit pas marcher hein
du tout hein dame prend G6 tour G7 ok
les Noirs euh pardon pas dame F6 ça
serait quand même un peu trop dam PR6
échec H8 et les Noirs une de plus bon il
a certes il y a trois pions mais c'est
pas assez clairement donc il va pas
faire ça est-ce que une idée comme ça
est jouable oui l'ORD dit adore les
blancs pourquoi je vais regarder il dit
B4 waouh ah ça il faut y penser à B4
pour faire
B5 pouf pas facile hein pas facile B4
honnêtement parce que ouais on on joue
on joue à ce jeu du de la souris depuis
déjà 5 coups et on a quand même envie de
de continuer j'ai trois jouets voyez
c'est le coup le plus naturel c'est un
coup que j'ai proposé ouais on regarde
de ce côté c'est normal c'est
humain G3 peut-être H5 c'est gentil
s420 comment on fait là H5 priori hein
ah il a le camion poubelle
ouais un défaut de Magnus ouais mauvais
perdent c'est un bon mais il faut haïir
la défaite c'est souvent les plus grands
champions peut-être qu'il l'a vu ce B4
parce que ça c'est une indication qu'il
a vu B4 il a joué puis on prend B2 ici
et alors H4 H5 tu fais quoi Magnus quand
même
camion poubelle là B je vais aller je
vais aller fermer la fenêtre
tiens à
l'enfer commence à faire froid de toute
façon alors G3 prends B2 et je comprends
pas du tout ce qui se passe sur
H4
et bien la Jae non plus faut 7 H5
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
Magnus je comprends rien bon mais
Magnus Magnus déjà foutu mvl gagnant H4
jou
évidemment 9 contre 8 on va voir la
réaction de
Magnus
incroyable incroyable salut à toi B
chess non on parle
en on parle en anglais hein
[Rires]
évidemment non pas du tout c'est pas un
joging pas du
tout pas du tout pas du tout c'est pas
un jogging c'est un pantalon euh
pantalon gris c'est un pantalon c'est un
pantalent je
déms je
dém alors H4 et ça va pas du
tout ça va pas du tout pour
euh Magnus qu'est-ce qu'il va jouer et
bien je crois qu'on aura notre match il
fait fou pr H4 mais bon
franchement pu on prend va arriver
évidemment puion on prend prend et
maintenant cavalier E4 je suppose tour
F2 d'où il fait
froid tour F2 et tour
G2 H4 puis on prend d Pr
ouais tour F2 a l'air très fort quand
même hein et en plus on menace que
perpète hein donc je peux même encasser
ici hein en vrai j'encasse ici la jauge
elle est pas contente mais bon en vrai
c'est bien c'est bien pour les
blancs je me fais traiter de menteur
ah non ah non non pas du tout d prend H4
tour prend B2 dam G3 ro H3 G1 et oui il
a fait ça c'est un chantage à la nulle
mais il va préférer perdre euh Magnus
Carlsen que faire nul c'est évident il
est obligé de la jouer
ouais il fait il est pas content il est
pas
content il peut pas prendre la nul et
oui mais c'est un chantage mais c'est un
chantage normal hein tour prend à de
OK et il fait nul et il accorde le gain
du match à Maxime va chez La Grave ok
bravo Maxime qui a
terrassé le géant norvégien dans ce
match vraiment
félicitations et euh alors pour
l'instant et ça le fait sourire Magnus
mais euh bah c'est pas drôle pour lui
parce que maintenant il a un deuxième
match mais mais c'est la dernière chance
ils ont
chacun ils ont chacun on va regarder le
bracket ils ont chacun gagné un match 2
et demi 1 et demi pour Maxime vach grave
il y a pas de départage de qui a gagné
qui a fait le plus de points et tout ça
non c'est un match chacun Magnus a gagné
mercredi Maxime vachagra vient de gagner
sous nos yeux et donc maintenant c'est
maintenant c'est pas fini hein ça la
partie la partie continue le match
continue maintenant et en fait ce qui se
passe c'est qu'ils ont chacun perdu un
match donc ils sont tous les deux des
losers entre guillemets
évidemment donc il tombent dans le loser
bracket entre guillemets et il joue un
match en deux
parties et donc c'est le match
des c'est la grande finale des joueurs
qui ont perdu un match chacun l'un
contre l'autre match de
départage deux
parties qui all les BL la première je
n'en sais rien mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils auront chacun les blancs chacun
les noirs et
ensuite s'il y a un partout on a droit à
l'Armageddon au spectacle absolu avec
cette mise ce temps qu'on met on fait
une enchère pour les Noirs les blanc 15
minutes quoi qu'il arrive ils sont
obligés de gagner quoi qu'il arrive et
une enchère pour savoir quel temps on
choisit avec les Noirs si les Noirs si
Magnus Carlsen dit 10 minutes Maxime
vachzagve dit 11 minutes Magnus Carlsen
all est noir avec 10 minutes et il a le
droit de faire match nul alors il l'
battu une fois c'est déjà un exploit
parce que dans ces champion chest tour
c'est déjà arrivé que Magnus gagne les
tournois sans perdre et maintenant c'est
gain du match à euh 2 et demi tout à
fait je vais changer
ça tout de suite
euh on va changer ça tout de
suite on va mettre à 1 et demi sous sous
vos yeux éba la technique est au top
aujourd'hui
et on va regarder gain du match à 1 et
demi on va regarder qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
dit aux joueurs c'est quand le prochain
match
ou
là
là prochaine partie dans 3 minutes qui
all les Blanque quielle est noir je n'en
sais
rien je n'en sais rien mais là on a pas
le temps de souffler les prochaines
parties dans 3
minutes le retour de la revanche en
finale et c'est comme c'est le modèle du
basket où on a le droit à une défaite et
à le droit de revenir on a le droit à
l'erreur là c'est vraiment c'est le
c'est le gros match
dans 2 minutes on
saura déjà qui est blanc alors je sais
pas est-ce qu'on le voit dans le bracket
ou pas est-ce qu'on alterne les couleurs
ou pas j'en sais rien peut-être que
Magnus est blanc
encore c'est possible c'est possible que
Magnus est les blanc encore son nom est
cité en premier à monaville les blanc
après je sais pas j'ai jamais été en
finale des losers donc là franchement je
sais pas
ça me paraît probable que Magnus et les
blancs mais attention on va
voir le format des tournois bon ben
c'est criticquable comme tout mais je
trouve ça pas mal quand
même c'est pas si
compliqué et simplement 5 minutes le
problème c'est les c'est les règles qui
changent en permanence c'est ça en
fait mais tournois double élimination
c'est quand même compréensible
c'est au judo ah c'est au judo il y a la
double élimination non mais il y a ces
play-off aussi au basket où on a 7 match
voilà la saison de play-off je vais
changer on va permuter tout ça et on a
Magnus Carlsen donc qui est de retour
plutôt et donc dans une
minute dans une minute on va avoir la
prochaine
partie c'est en deux parties premiierre
arrivée à 1 et demi s'il y a un partout
on a un
Armagedon
pou ça va être chaud ça va être
chaud il a gagné il a gagné il a gagné
le premier match ou je remets à zéro on
remet les compteur à zéro bien sûr quand
on met les compteurs à zéro c'est un
nouveau match il a perdu mercredi il a
gagné vendredi on refait un match
vendredi et on va voir il a été auus
dans ce match c'est mérité hein ça il y
a pas de problème c'est mérité mais
Magnus pas inquiet Magnus pas
inquiet il a l'air calme Magnus
Carlsen on va
voir on va voir s'il a raison d'être
calme ou pas enfin il a été ouais il a
été en dessous notamment cette première
partie où il a un peu trop forcé et
puis maxime a bien pris sa chance il a
eu une chance dans la partie il l'a
prise hein tout de suite il a été
épatant Maxime va chez La
Grave et on a Magnus Carlsen qui a les
blanc comme prévu on va tourner Chequer
tout de suite je vous l'avais annoncé et
on a encore un gamidam accepté ça s'est
évidemment très bien passé est-ce que
Maxime a eu le temps de regarder ses
notes ou pas on va voir la réponse tout
de suite c'est toujours du 15 + 3 et il
joue C5 cette fois il change ici alors
il nous laisse pas le temps du coup F3
rock A3 fou A5 fou E3 il avait joué
cavalier fd7 mais il allait checker ses
notes et il a vu que c'était C5 le coup
puis on prend C5
dame8 dame D6 jouer très vite fou E6 et
grand ro Magnus Carlsen qui a bien fait
ses devoirs apparemment pour ce match
ouais Magnus Carlsen normalement favori
mais alors là ça se joue à rien
peut-être si galité sur la deuxème
partie vous allez aller voir ce qui se
passe c'est l'ARM mageddon grand rock
jouet ça Blitz et là Magnus qui essaie
vraiment peut-être un jour ou là là là
dame C8 ou là
attends attention quand même euh on va
on va faire ça au ralenti parce que là
je suis comme vous he dame D6 F 6 c'est
clairement la prépa grand R dame C8 k
prend B5 dame C8 pourquoi dame C8 parce
qu'on menacer fou C7 pourquoi C prend B5
parce qu'on prend un pion et on empêche
fou C7 A6 ah aïe k D4 fou
C7 si on fait dame 7 il a fou prend le 5
donc ça ne va pas du tout on fait k il
prend le 6 ça c'est étudié hein fou
prend des6 tour prend les 6 puis on
prend 6 F prend C4 bilan de
fou 1 2 3
pion donc 9 points contre la dame moi on
m'a pris c'était 10 points la dame
bon apparemment c'est
donc tour8 et C6 et très très bien
développé pour les blancs on va jouer
tour D1 ensuite mais la jauge qui met
euh alors d'un point de vue
humain à mon à mon jugement à moi les
Noirs ont une
poubelle après c'est plus complexe estce
que ça ah mais non mais pardon je
raconte n'importe quoi au niveau des
points il manque un
cavalier
donc donc oui ça me semblait beaucoup en
fait on a deux fous pour la dame deux
fous trois pions le rapport matériel
c'est ça deux fous tris pions pour dame
cavalier pardon et oui donc avantage
matériel pour les Noirs c'est je me
disais aussi c'est bizarre c'est bizarre
c'est bizarre mais voilà on voit des
pièces qui ont du mal à sortir regardez
justement cette tour qui peut pas sortir
le fou contrôle donc c'est des
compensations quand même qui sont très
très belles hein pour les Noirs un roi
chacun ouais comme dirait Bul chess tout
à fait mon cher
Tonton comment on fait ici avec les
Noirs oh là j'en ai aucune idée a 5
cavalier a 6 pour sortir à tour non il
fait tour 7 assez rapidement pour faire
tous ces 7 fou B6 menace tour D8 menace
évidente menace vu par tout le chat mais
jou à tempo c'est toujours la prépa de
Magnus certainement je peux pas en dire
plus parce que je me souviens pas et ça
c'est bien je me souviens honnêtement
j'ai déjà regardé cette ligne et c'était
pas pour mon
compte donc vous pouvez imaginer pour
qui je l'ai fait ce ce travail j'ai pas
été le seul à regarder ça mais
honnêtement je n'ai aucun souvenir c'est
ça qui est beau je me rappelle que c'est
chaud je me rappelle que ça va pour les
Noirs mais que c'est chaud pour les
noirs et c'est5 ça me dit quelque chose
effectivement C5 é le coup principal
donc voilà toute cette ligne elle a été
analysée jusqu'ù je me demandais pas
j'en sais rien fa que j'ouvre mon ordi
peut-être qu'il a retravaillé depuis
j'en sais rien
kbd7 joué rapidement par Maxime puis on
prend les 7 jou à tempo alors c'est bon
signe pour Maxime c'est bon et mauvais
signe pour Maxime qu'est-ce qui est bon
signe ça veut dire qu'il a pas fait de
gaffe parce qu'il
joue Magnus continue jouer de jouer à
tempo mais ça veut dire que Magnus con
est encore plus on peut pas on peut pas
s'arrêter sur cette position ou alors il
a des très mauvaises entraîneurs mais il
on sait qu'il a des bons entraîneurs
Magnus
carlsen6 jou à tempo pour ramasser le
cavalier bil matériel parce qu'on y
comprend rien ça va trop vite on est
d'accord on a perdu un
cavalier alors c'est quoi on a paire de
fou cette fois c'est vrai et de pions
donc 8 points contre la dame mais on a
réussi à sortir tour8 qui est une gaff
d'après la
jauge le coup
était alors la je faible c'est roi H8
apparemment comme ça sur C prend7 les
dam prend C4 sur tour8 le coup c'est fou
3 d'après la jauge qui donne un avantage
de plus un point pour les blancs alors
c'est pas un avantage matériel mais
c'est simplement un avantage de
compensation
fou3 et ensuite ça va être très dur de
sortir pour les Noirs mais là il change
d'avis il dit dame B7 on va laisser
réfléchir après tour8 et non tour8 c'est
le coup tour8 faut 3 jou tempo ou
qu-y et maintenant on va laisser
réfléchir il montrit dame B7 après une
petite réflexion qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur dame B7 qui a l'air logique hein
pour faire tour
C8 pou quelle pagaille si on fait tour
D1 qui est quand même le coup évident il
y a tour à C8 sur tour D1 et sur tour
prendre D7 dam prend C6 ça n'irait pas
bon là c'est vraiment les échecs les
échecs
modernes avec une énorme prépa
dordi paire de fou versus dame
ouais ah pardon ouais excusez-moi
l'chequier d'analyse n'a pas le même
orientation que le merci de me le dire
merci de me le dire et ouais il y a eu
trop j'ai pas eu le temps de j'ai pas eu
le réflexe de changer trop de choses se
sont passées sur échéquier on peut pas
être
partout si on peut on essaie d'être
partout mais bon c'est
compliqué c'est un truc de
dingue mais très théorique donc n B7 et
le bon coup
ici non maistenant il m H8 je comprends
pas en profondeur voyez moi ce que j'ai
là sur sous mes yeux là j'ai mis la
variante j'ai profondeur 23 de stock
fish
15 donc c'est pas mal provendeur 23 ça
banne n'importe quel être humain mais
clairement il travaille pas avec ce
genre d'ordi hein là ils sont déjà à
profondeur 40 donc c'est un c'est dur il
y a pas trop d'erreur normalement à
profondeur 23 mais quand même là il dit
roi H8 il montrer dame B7 tout à l'heure
dame B7 moi me semble tout à fait mieux
on va laisser
réfléchir sur dame B7
ouais là c'est le travail dans second an
hein c'est l'ordi de de chesscom mais
c'est le travail dans second de savoir
attendre au bon moment c'est ça le
principal travail c'est de
savoir quand il faut attendre ou pas
oui oui je pense que Maxime a des vagues
souvenirs il a quand même dépensé pas
mal de temps 950 là donc là ça y est il
a des vagues souvenir mais il se
souvient plus il se souvient
officiellement
plus et il est pas habitué à voir ça de
la part de Magnus dans ses parties
online mais il a décidé
Magnus Carlsen là c'est le signe moi je
le connais Magnus quand c'est comme ça
quand il va prépa contre prépa c'est qui
considère que son adversaire est très
très dangereux et qu'il est pas assez en
forme pour le battre par pure classe
donc il dit ok ok gameon moi aussi je
les prép pas je vais essayer de
t'attraper de te mettre la pression
parce que tu me joues une variante qui
est quand
même qui est quand même
difficile intéressant
intéressant tout
ça passionnant même mais dur à jouer
hein dur à jouer si on a pas la si on a
pas la
ref j'ai l'impression en
plus est-ce que ça serait pas dame B7 le
coup la jauge dit que non mais elle
change d'avis la jauge
ouais dame B7 et surtour prend6
t prend 6 3 H8 il dit que c'est
n'importe quoi B7 tour C8 si Dame B7 est
possible vraiment je vois pas de
contreindication dame C7
jouer mais alors le problème c'est que
sur tour à C8 on menacera pas tour prend
C6 c'est ça l'inconvénient donc dame C7
il va jouer tour D1 Magnus cararlsen
c'est quasiment certain sur fou prend E6
il y a tour prend tour prend cavalier F8
fini ça c'est quand même pas très dur à
voir on peut pas trouver une tour une
case pour la tour sur la 6e qui protège
le cavalier donc compliqué donc ça perd
donc dame C7 touraged1 va être joué
c'est quasi
certain et maintenant c'est vrai qu'on
on va jouer cavalier F F probablement
c'est ça son
idée cavalier F F8 a été joué à tempo
par Maxime Vacher la grave qui pouvait
se douter de
tourd et maintenant on a deux fou de
pions contre la dame donc 8 points
contre 9 ou 10 ça dépend comment on
compte et là qui montre avantage blanc
et surtout plus de 5 minutes d'avance
donc
clairement
clairement on a on a une prépa qui a
bien marché pour les
blancs sans vouloir me vanter
ouais aussi non mais il joue des prépas
quand il Magnus dé prép pas aussi quand
il s en
danger il décide OK
ok c'est sérieux
maintenant mon adversaire se prépare il
y a pas de raison que je parte avec un
handicap dans l'ouverture par exemple
Magnus Carlsen des des matchs de
championnat du monde ou des parties de
tournoi il y a pas besoin d'être un
expert pour comprendre que c'est
différent il est beaucoup beaucoup mieux
préparé il prend ça il prend la prépa
beaucoup plus au sérieux quand c'est mat
championnat du monde d'où d'ailleurs
l'équipe qui gonflait à chaque fois par
exemple pour le dernier match on été 5
voilà et pour les tournois de l'année on
est est on était que deux donc
effectivement ça change des
choses la jauge sa profondeur c'est 22
donc c'est pas extraordinaire mais quand
même c'est plus fort que Magnus et
Maxime
ouais on peut quand même globalement se
fi à la juge qui va très rarement se
tromper principalement elle va se
tromper uniquement dans ce genre de
position où il y a un gros déséquilibre
et roi B1 roi H8 et en fait en gros il
dit Magnus que il fait H4 il va
améliorer gentiment sa position et il
dit qu'il est mieux sur le long terme H6
joué par mvl qui voit pas trop quoi
faire tour à C8 c'est ça fil un pion on
n pas envie de filer un pion en
plus mais comment on améliore vraiment
alors est-ce qu'on fait une sorte de
pousser à l' roi pour essayer
d'affaiblir le roi ça se ça se
réfléchit
G4 qu'est-ce que ça voulait dire un
second ça doit savoir attendre ça veut
dire qu'il faut attendre la profondeur
de l'ordinateur qui monte petit à petit
plus on laisse de temps à l'ordinateur
plus il va monter en profondeur plus il
va calculer
donc donc parfois dansard de
position clairement il faut
attendre clairement
ou alors se fait piéger par techfess à
cause de non moi j'ai participé à ce
truc là j'ai pas je l'ai déjà vu ce
truc- je l' regardé un peu c'est sûr
mais j'ai pas été le
seul j'ai pas été le seul à le regarder
ça c'est sûr qui exactement a trouvé
quoi j'en sais rien
ouais bon c'est vrai que Peter he il
pourrait faire semblant de pas connaître
du tout de pas savoir qu'est-ce que
c'est comme ouverture en garamais
accepté ah bon ah mais c'est marrant de
prendre un pion aussitôt voilà il ferait
un truc comme ça bon je vais pas vous
mentir voilà c'est
clairement clairement un truc qui a été
regardé il y a mais il y a longtemps
donc ça peut certainement été reg
regardé depuis donc G4 dam F7 ça été
regardé avant que ça soit à la mode
maintenant c'est plus à la
mode non non ouais
oui c'est ça les joueurs perdent contre
la jauge profondeur 22 ça oui dans les
ouvertures on les bat mais après
n'importe qui perd quoi après for 22 on
perd contre les ordinateurs même Magnus
Caval 5 dame F6 donc cavali 5 est
apparemment la première ga fou des 4
c'est vrai que c'est tentant de faire ça
il y a plein de coup joué DG4 donc il se
il se dirigeait bien contre le roi il a
bien raison dame F7 attaque le pion
cavalier E5 le défend dame F6 et fou D4
c'est vra que c'est hyper tentant de
créer ce vis-à-vis alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe sur dam pr H4 et bien euh je ne
sais pas apparemment le coup c'est foupr
aussi je vais enlever ce truc de d'ordi
parce que là c'est infernal et sur k
prend 6 il a C G6 donc on récupère notre
pion dame prend H4 a été joué faut
prendre 6 aussi rapidement 12 minutes
contre 650 et la jauge qui est
redescendue donc ça c'est très bon signe
pour
mvl pou
ouais les parties par correspondance
sont celles évidemment qui sont les
mieux joués donc c'est généralement
regarder il y a les parties par
correspondance les parties
d'ordinateur bah à ton avis Jules est-ce
qu'on a des énormes serveurs ou des
petits laptops à l'ancienne Essie de
deviner
essaie de deviner pour un match un peu à
du monde à ton avis est-ce que c'est le
petit laptop à l'ancienne tu as ton
petit stock fish là ou c'est tu te
connectes sur un
Cloud ah je pense qu'en 2023 la réponse
paraît assez
évidente damage
2 joué par Maxime l'idée c'est qu'on
attaque ici je comprends rien cette
partie et sur fou F5 je suppose qu'on ve
faire tour prend 5
intéressant quel tacticien ce Maxime al
échec qu'est-ce que ça donne échec c'est
pas bon dès que je joue un coup tout
seul vous voyez c'est la c'est le
désastre
c'est ro G8 on se met dansche double
donc ça pe terrible ro H7 je voulais
faire échec G6 et ça va pas ah non le
coup c'est ro G8 attaque le cavalier ah
ouais c'est joli ça et si on bouge le
cavalier la tour est en
prise choc de titan fou des5 ah ilataque
la tour oh là là il attaque dans tous
les sens et là fou des5 il a joué ro H7
à tempo bon c'est juste monstrueux c'est
juste monstrueux parce que je suis pas
sur tourb8 il tour qui
menac non c'était quoi sur sur tour B8
je comprends rien c'était juste
F4 F4 défi pourquoi R7 est bien parce
qu'il y a plus de
F4 et pourquoi je pouvais pas faire
attends je comprends F D5 tour B8 F4
qu'est-ce qui se passe dame pr F4 il y a
tour pr H6
maintenant
sur pion prank G6 éche double sur dame
prankalier7 ça c'est par contre ça c'est
sûr que c'est foutu les de fous comme ça
on a fou de pion contre la qualité mais
ok les fous sont vraiment très fort ça
se voit wou il comprend tout ça tempo il
joue H7 c'est assez dingue ce qui se
passe c'est H7 c'est un coup de monstre
sacré Maxime qu'est-ce qu'il est bon
dans ces
positions
qu'est-ce qu'il est
bon je sais pas je sais pas je sais pas
comment qualifier ce coup droit la
première ligne de
l'ordi alors attendez mais je pas c'est
ça enlève les T les tour pr mais ça
donne quand même est-ce que je peux pas
encaisser là ouais c'est le bon coup
d'ailleurs prend
prend
8 et l'ordi aime bien les
blancs fou C3 bon pourquoi pas est-ce
que j'ai 5 pour
ouvrir waouh g 5 il monte tour8 puis on
prend H6 T prend5 H prend G7
intermédiaire r prend G7 t prend6 ro F7
F prend
prend cette finale sonelon l'ordi est un
peu mieux pour les blancs mais
globalement annulable OK
ça ça a du sens G5 jouer par G5 direct
G5 est une énorme gaffe de la part de
Magnus Carlsen il a tour C8 ici men
C2 wou wou
wou il a oublié d'être matérialiste
Magnus
Carlsen T8 jou très vite par par Maxime
grave c'est improbable ce qui se passe
dans cette dans ce match
et bien et
bien c'est joué de manière incroyable il
est gagnant maintenant d'après la juge
Maxime va chez La Grave il a retourné
cette position en deux coups de cuillère
à peau mais quel joueur quand il est
comme ça
waouh
c'est improbable
ou là al je sais pas si vous avez vu
mais Magnus a commencé à dire des mots
en norvégien ce qui me rappelle mes
parties de tennis avec Magnus
[Musique]
Carlsen
il il disait d'abord des mots après
j'entendais ah oui il y avait un truc
frç il y av un truc avec les Français il
déclarait son amour pour la pour la
France quand il venait de
rater je visisais un coup gagnant au
tennis ou qui venait de rater un truc au
tennis
waouh ça parle et il doit se dire quel
crétin quel crétin de pas avoir pris un8
tout de suite j'ai oublié que tour C8
menacé d'ame C2 et d'encaisser la tour
mais alors là ce qui me semble
complètement improbable c'est que le
coup de la jauge c'est
ça qu'est-ce qui se passe sur ça je
comprends rien ça ça ça
ça pourquoi pas H8 déjà parce qu'il y a
fou B3 F7
ok bon faut le
voir F
prend et ok ça a l'air complètement
gagnant quand même pour les Noirs
ouais ouais il va pas jouer F F7 c'est
quasiment certain mais comment on fait
pour empêcher C2 et tu reprends le 5
aussi he tu reprends le 5 fait très
mal il le
regarde il le regarde Maxime il a le
droit il le
zoom il regarde le zoom il dit qu'est-ce
que tu as encore
raté qu'est-ce que tu as encore raté mon
jeune
ami incroyable incroyable ce qu'il fait
c'est dingue c'est dingue c'est XXL la
performance de mvl dans ce match et donc
s'il g cette partie avec les Noirs il
aura alors attends c'est pas fini il
aura simplement une nulle à faire avec
les Blancs alors tour C6 c'est un bon
coup pratique ouais tour pr cavalier pr
et on garde quand même ce fou fou et
pion de de fou pion contre la dame bon
ça reste chaud H5 est le meilleur coup
d'après la jauge ok ça a du sens est-ce
que si je fais un truc d'encaisseur de
pion c'est bien aussi ouais et ensuite
on va faire cavalier H4
pour les Noirs écoutez 1 c'est la limite
gagnant pas
complètement pas complètement fini
ouais le coup de la jauge est quand même
fou alors pr G5 oui comme d'ab Maxime il
encaisse les pion H5 était meilleur
mais5 évidemment le coup
humain la F 3 c'est pas si clair 060
elle baisse lae
c'est improbable ce qui se passe dans ce
match qu pagaille
indescriptible mais quel match de Maxim
F7 Atta la tour en même temps c'est
logique7 mais c'est pas bon du tout t
C8 va jou quoi d'autre franchement
il
fait
sourcil ile il a bien raison j
C8 la
partier mais ça n'avait pas de sens
qu'il a
fait ça perd un temps ça perd un temps
mais grosse partie c'est pas fini c'est
pas
fini mais c'est énorme ce qu' fait
Maxime parce que pour survivre cette
prépa c'était quand même c'était quand
même quelque
chose effectivement Magnus qui a parlé
en norvégien
fan il c'est jur
préféré
alors j'ai l'impression qu'il faut
revenir c'est clairement mais bon
effectivement Magnus remarque il a pas
de mal à reconnaître ses
ses ses erreurs mon micro grés oh non
j'espère que
non j'espère que non dites-moi que c'est
pas
vrai dites-moi que c'est pas vrai s'il
vous plaît
ça me ferait mal au
cœur s'il vous plaît pitier jeir des
messages partout ça grés pas qu'est-ce
qu'il fait Magnus là il y a pas d'autres
coup
tour C1 il voulait faire
ouais peut-être mais bon tour un damage
3 apparemment il y a un problème sur F3
il joue F 5 Magnus carlen ah cétait ça
idée mais ça perd tout de suite F 5 dam
g2+ 3 pour les Noirs selon e il fait
n'importe quoi il perd toute la la
coordination
ah Magnus ouais non d'accord Magnus fait
des gaffes mais bah oui mais pour gagner
une partieéchec faut être deux faut
aussi
des des des mauvais coups de
l'adversaire
clairement donc bon ça joue des deux
côtés c'est
évident dame G2 k
D4 quoi
d'autre
non pas du tout ouais non mais d'accord
ok ah ça ça va être
ban non non non non ça ban pour les gens
qui disent que ça
grés ah très très
léger ah
ouais ah c'est très léger
merde
incroyable ah il est saturé quand je
parle fort
ou d'accord jouer par Magnus Carlsen je
vais essayer de avoir d'avoir quelque
chose on attend pas les girons de Magnus
ouais
ah je vais baisser le
son ouais ouais si si
il a oui non ouais d'accord d'accord
ouais non mais je sais quand je parle
fort j'ai mis un peu trop fort peut-être
ah c'est un réglage permanent ce
sont allez k D4 on protège
F3 et si on arrête de regarder la Jae
c'est ça pas l'air si clair mais avec la
Jae c'est plus 3 c'est quand même c'est
le
problème77 pour ramener la cavalerie à
l'attaque et c'est vrai que ça a l'air
de faire mal et c'est pas très compliqué
ouais ouais non
effectivement
d'accord merci merci à tous pour le
retour sur le son parce que on peut
faire tous les tests du monde et Tonton
on le sait bien le direct c'est quand
même c'est le moment de
vérité
alors on peut les retrouver sur sur
chesscom les parties vous allez dans
regarder et vous pouvez les repartir
pour les pour les voir àêtre à G4 ahouis
ou a beaucoup de sens surpion prend G4
il dame prend E4 ça c'est un coup très
très logique et c'est un très bon coup
d'après la juge mais surpion prend
attention dame prend roi 1 dame prend 5
ne marche pas c'est
ma donc pion prend G4 va être joué à mon
avis puis on prend G4 il veut faire k D7
certainement puis on prend G4 jouer d
prend le 4 jouer ouais c'était l'idée ro
mais en fait en vrai il va pas
évidemment qu'il va pas prendre Maxime
il est pas fou non plus il va avoir le
mat du cou roi de jouer mais ça perd de
l'avantage au niveau euh du logiciel
mais alors
franchement franchement ah le son a
changé depuis le début du tournoi parce
que j'ai j'ai augmenté un petit peu le
volume parce que j'ai vu que c'était bas
moi sur mon ordi portable donc voilà
j'ai changé alors le temps pour Maxime
de 30 contre 4 minutes mais bon ça reste
quand même dans le domaine du raisonable
et on peut pas prendre le roi est un peu
dans les courants d'air mais après tout
on a du matériel en plus que c'est chaud
c'est bouillantissime voilà s'il y a pas
d'autres mots c'est incroyablement chaud
mais Maxime il est quand un poisson dans
l'eau dans ses parti et donc ça serait
pas étonnant quand même que Maxime
euh Maxime benelle emporte tout
simplement il est favori mais attention
de 10 contre 4 minutes ça peut fatiguer
aussi G6 c'est le meilleur coup d'après
la jauge injouable selon moi k D7
qu'est-ce qui se passe k D7 ça redevient
égal après fou D6
waouh waouh et des7 va être joué non
tour des 8 a été joué qu'est-ce que
c'est tour des 8 c'est un bon coup quand
même ça clou ouais là c'est impossible
il y a tellement d'options pour les deux
camps à chaque
coup que ça en devient
injouable injouable et
injugeable attention quand même on
menace de perdre tout de suite là avec
les avec les Blancs il faut jouer tour
F1 là mais alors allez allez savoir
allez savoir allez savoir
pourquoi tour F le meilleur coup et k 6
bon mais c'est injouable c'est
complètement injouable on va juste
kiffer avec nos yeux là parce que c'est
juste c'est juste dingue ce qui est en
train de se passer mais c'est la pose du
roi noir fait peur mais la dame est sous
contrôle c'est l'avantage d'avoir une
dame mon cher Tonton c'est qu'elle va en
elle va horizontale verticale diagonale
elle est elle est partout elle est
partout la dame c'est le gros avantage
sur une tour ou sur un fou qui ne fait
qu'une seule de ces deux choses
et donc on est content d'avoir cette
dame alors tour des de tour H2 oua tour
des2 tour des de PR 5 attention contrôle
la case et mange le fou c'était une
bonne idée quand même ça ma fait peur
pendant 2 secondes alors comment il fait
là Magnus Carlsen il a pas l'air bien
Magnus et oui il est en difficulté il
est en difficulté contre Maxime
ouais les deux coups les deux coups sont
dur à trouver les deux camps 2 40 contre
2 c'est
ingérable c'est complètement
ingérable cette fin de de partie c'est
irrespirable 2 30 contre 2 t meilleur
coup d'après lae jeets lauge allez je
craque je comprends rien sinon tour F
mais
alors t qu'est-ce qu'on joue
d'aut c'est ça la question on va
ESS de se déclouer c'est logique t on
sait qu'on peut pas prendre ici parce
qu'
mat et tour F l'idée sur7 c'est de faire
cavalier F3 et F3 gagne d'ailleurs tour
F1 joué par Magnus Carlsen qui vend
chermer sa peau tour des7 ici est le bon
coup pour menacer tour pr F7 tout
simplement il est ennuyeux ce fou il
commence à nous fatiguer ce fou il nous
pompe l'air tour D7 cavalier F3 c'est la
ligne tour prend F7 k G5 ça serait la
bonne ligne roi G6 k prend E4 tour prend
F1 évidemment je vois passer à tempo je
suis aidé par l'ordinateur
vous vous êtes pas naïf à ce point là
quand même tour G1 k prend à 6 et
ensuite on pousse les pions mais
apparemment les noirs sont devant mais
alors allez savoir il peut s'en passer
les choses tour des7 et le coup
important à trouver ro H6 r H6 k F5
échec quand même ciel bleu
attention tour des7 et un super coup et
c'est vrai que c'est logique d'enlever
ce fou mais bon c'est facile à dire dame
G2 joué par mvl et là il y a tour
F5 et c'est à peu près égal rendez-vous
compte au miracle au miracle de la
jauge c'est égal d'après la
jauge pourquoi pourquoi B parce que la
jauge le dit l'oracle le dit mais alors
une 40 contre une 12 c'est évidemment
une partie à 3 résultat tout peut se
passer dans ces deux prochaines minutes
de trois prochaines minutes et la magie
de ce jeu c'est qu'on ne sait absolument
pas ce qui va se passer c'est ça la
magie c'est qu'on sait pas on ne sait
pas on a deux grands champions face de
nous et trois résultats trois résultats
possibles je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
je sais je peux vous dire quelque chose
je la perdrai avec les deux couleurs
contre n'importe lequel de ces deux
joueurs voilà ça c'est la certitude tour
F5 jouer menace mend un coup là faut
s'organiser quand même G6 c'est le coup
G6 va être joué c'est
obligatoire ah on peut pas faire autre
chose attention Maxime à pas se mettre
trop mal au temps il est passé enous de
la minute je vois pas d'autre coup
qu'est-ce qu'il nous fait pourquoi il
réfléchit j'ai 6 jouet tour F6 c'est le
coup maintenant en même temps il y a pas
cases mais Magnus qui réfléchit
évidemment qu'il réfléchit parce que
c'est tellement
complexe quelle quelle quelle angoisse
quelle angoisse une 10 contre 50
secondes oh les deux joueurs là qui
jouent qui jouent une partie sublime et
d'une complexité
rare que ceux qui disent que les échecs
sont sont morts a se
rhabiller parce que là il y a de quoi
faire des erreurs je vous le dis dame
prend G4 et le bon coup d'après lauge
018 pour les
noirs6 parce que T prend les quatre
menaces je ne sais pas du tout ce qui va
se passer je ne sais pas je crois que la
position des blanc est quand même plus
facile à jouer cavalier F3 qui a encore
un mauvais coup d'après lae tour des
gagne pour Maxime tour des TR et vu par
mvl oh là là il fait ses gaff Magnus
c'est quand même assez
incroyable c'est quand même
délirant il est complètement foutu tour
des TR qui est quand même assez simple
on attaque deux fois la
pièce oh Magnus Carlsen complètement
foutu 35 secondes par blanc c'est
quasiment
rappé pour le match en tout
cas
là je vois pas je vois pas mais Maxime
va chzagve qui est gagnant qui est
gagnant qui est complètement
gagnant incroyable Magnus Carlsen qui
rate à chaque fois qui est moins bon
dans ce time scrumble comme on dit dans
cette crise de temps mutuelle il est il
est moins bon que Maxime en tout cas
aujourd'hui fout des 5 joué tour prend
des5 il veut jouer tour prend
F8 mais il y a pas dame C4 là tour prend
D5 jouer tour F7 échec d'abord ok r
H6 et maintenant fou G7 jouer r H5 va
être joué évidemment pr de pièces mais
c'est pas suffisant du tout alors
attention dame C4 apparemment et le bon
coup dame C4 jou B3 dame 2 et fou B2
mais ça va pas être assz on a maintenant
on a même plus la paire de fou et le Roi
peut
naviguer peut naviguer en PER pénard
sur l' blanche mais alors que c'est
chaud G4 jou évidemment c'est
complètement gagnant pour Max sa-ce qu'
son on sait
pas c'estz improbable j par Magnus de
mieux
10 c'est complè termin c'est faile jouer
mainten
jou34 je crois que c'est facile quand
même et ro4 est le plus précis et c'est
joué par mvl oh là là on a mvl de gala
G3 B6
G2 tour des 8 tour des 8 ça termine le
travail et oui et c'est terminé il va
abandonner Magnus Carlsen et 0 pour
Maxime ou là là là petit coup de colère
il a Mar il est pas habitué à se faire
marcher dessus de cette manière par
Magnus par mvl et par n'importe qui
d'autre c'est incroyable ce qui se passe
dans ce match mais ma
une nulle avec les Blancs d'emporter
cette artificial intelligence Cup quelle
performance encore une fois de la part
de
Maxime on a on a rarement vu Magnus
pousser dans ces derniers retranchement
comme ça et en difficulté et même
maintenant Maxime vacheragve gros favori
pour remporter ce match et ben c'est
fatigant oh là 5 minutes de break
attendez moi je je je fais un petit
break là je vous mets pub hein vous y
avez
droit et bien c'est quand même
improbable ce qui se passe et la
revanche est
dans 6 minutes quand même il disent 5
minutes de break mais ils annoncent un
horaire différent bon on va on va
prendre ça
et petite pub faut que je souffle bravo
Maxime c'est pas fini il va falloir
encore tenir avec les blanc mais en tout
cas grosse partie grosse partie
vraiment incroyable
je reviens tout de suite je souffle
merci à tout de
[Musique]
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est incroyable
ce
euh j' par mon latin c'est incroyable
euh on a la chance d'assister à ce match
qui est complètement fou où Maxime
vachagrab est en train de renverser
Magnus Carlsen il a gagné le match en
quatre parties 2 et demi 1 et demi et il
a gagné la première avec les Noirs
rendez-vous compte il a besoin que d'une
nulle avec les Blancs pour gagner cette
artificial intelligence Cup c'est
incroyable ce qu'il est en train de nous
faire Maxime il a été énorme
pendant toute la semaine il a été euh il
a été fort on l'a senti déjà mercredi
même quand il a perdu ce match il est
bien revenu hier et il est en train de
faire plus que douter euh Magnus Carlsen
il est en train de mener contre Magnus
cararlsen aussi simple que ça il a les
blancs il a besoin d'une nulle
et une nulle et c'est gagné et c'est
gagné pour Maxime on va voir et c'est
parti et on a une Sicilienne pour cette
dernière partie Magnus Carlsen qui
montre des signes de faiblesse là et on
a une française avec
une je rcre n'importe quoi une sicilien
avec E6 au deuxième
coup et on va voir ce que va jouer
Magnus est-ce qu'il va jouer si mvl fait
nul c'est gagné est-ce qu'il va jouer
kf6 kc3 kc6 ou kc6 directement ou autre
chose ou à 6 la canne et ben oui c'est à
6 ok j'aurais paré sur kc6 au moment où
j'allais dire je paris sur kc6 et bien
euh il a
joué il a jouer A6 et C4 qui est une des
Vares les plus solides qui est C3 dame
C7 OK et on va jouer un truc qui un
système hérisson avec B7 B6 7 quelque
chose comme ça mais ça mauvaise
réputation pour les pour les Noirs donc
les normalement les les blancs sont très
bien mais c'est le problème d'avoir
besoin de gagner
euh avec les Noirs c'est qu'on est
obligé de faire des choses plus ou moins
douteuses et bien on va voir fou 3 joué
rapidement par euh maximeagra qui a été
impérial de depuis le début le gagnant
est qualifié pas pour les candidats mais
pour la la grande finale du champion
chest tour à Toronto ça fait par ça fait
pas partie du cycle pas encore pas
encore mais bientôt ça fera partie du
cycle à mon avis des candidats on
qualifiera aussi les joueurs d'ailleurs
on commence à mettre il y a il y a le le
le circuit FIDÉ hein qui donne une place
au candidat qui inclut des parties
rapides déjà et ça va être de plus en
plus comme ça parce que pourquoi ces
parties rapides ne compteraient pas
autant ou au moins ne compteraiit pas du
tout dans le cycle je trouve pas ça très
logique c'est quand même des échecs
c'est parties rapide envoie des des
échecs de haute qualité dans ces parties
rapides il y a aucun
problème que celui qui me dise le
contraire soit capable de reconnaître
une partie de Magnus Carlsen ou de
Maxime vach grave en rapide ou en
classique si on montre comme ça la
partie par exemple la deuxième partie
est-ce qu'on peut déduire si c'est du
rapide ou des classiques bien malin moi
en tout cas j'en suis bien incapable ça
joue quand même très très bien en partie
rapide
aussi pas forcément moins bien
d'ailleurs peut-être un peu moins bien
mais pas beaucoup fou D6 attaque H 2
maintenant évidemment ça veut provoquer
F4 pour faire fou C5 mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment un mauvais deal pour les
pour les blancs j'en sais rien et il
décide que non Maxime il joue très vite
et très appliqué comme
toujours on va
voir
oh c'est pas ouais 500000 dans la poche
je crois pas 500000 c'est le 20œur du
champion ch quiche 5 500000 je pense pas
non non non non mais il y a des bons
prix ouais déjà c'est 30000 pour ce
tournoi et plus la Calif ça doit être au
moins 100000 le le vainqueur du du de
Toronto ça doit être au moins 100000
donc ça vaut le coup quand même ça vaut
le coup d'aller passer la semaine à
Toronto
k C6 kc2 est s'appliquer sur ces parties
il y a des énormes prix dans ces
tournois
online alors K c'est2 et k prend3 menace
aussi ouais mais ça va être fini ça pour
des raisons culturelles les vrais échecs
c'est cadence c'est fini c'est en train
de changer déjà c'est fini ce
temps-là les choses bougent et souvent
euh pour le pour la bonne
cause parce que qui regarde des parties
classique de A à Z c'est très très
rare est-ce que les parties rapidees ça
vous est tous arrivé de de regarder les
parties rapides de A à Z
ouais et il y a moins de prépa il y a
moins de prépa en parti rapide on peut
plus facilement rattraper une heure de
prépa donc il décide de faire D6 ok mes
dames des de ouais il joue très
logiquement très solidement il a un beau
maro
mvl il peut même faire B4 pour forcer la
décision et reprendre du cavalier ici
c'est très confort pour les blancs cette
position tour à il fait jouer tout le
monde il joue de manière très bien très
logique comme depuis le début du tournoi
Maxime il est très bien il est en
contrôle ici dans cette position on va
voir si Magnus arrive à à poser des
problèmes ça va pas être évident
c'est certain tellement la position des
blancs est
saine alors je sais pas quels sont les
prix du du de la grande finale au
champion
cheour 1 demi million ça me semble
beaucoup mais bon euh c'est pas
impossible c'est pas impossible
ouais et puis bon après par rapport à
d'autres sports c'est quand même
ridicule
hein donc
voilà ah oui 500000 c'est le price total
ouais
ce qui est quand même énorme pour un
tournoi d'une semaine c'est c'est quand
même énorme kg4 ok on F sa décision on
en est pas là après je suis pas sûr à à
% que euh si je crois que chaque
vainqueur de de des tournois comme ça
est qualifié pour Toronto pour la grande
finale donc c'est pour ça que c'est
important pour
pour pour Maxime ce tournoi quel est le
plan des Noirs ben justement c'est ça le
problème puis on prend et refaire tour
des8 ok c'est pas mal ça pour essayer de
forcer la décision sur la colonne D
j'aime bien ce qu'a fait Magnus là kg4
était pas mal F prend C 5 D prend
C5 et maintenant c'est tour un peu bête
sur cette sur cette colonne sur ces
colonnes
ok euh Magnus a créé encore une fois il
a réussi à créer du jeu alors ça s'était
éteint rapidement dans cette
carocane mais là euh là ça paraît euh ça
paraît quand même
être une position complètement jouable
et très intéressante on rappelle que si
Maxime vachz la grave ne perd pas cette
partie il
remporte le tournoi si perd cette partie
un Armagedon et ça sera terminé de toute
façon donc là c'est vraiment vous vivez
les dernières les dernières minutes de
ce match qui vont
être peut-être encore plus folles que le
reste mais alors là
ouais 2 millions de cash price sur toute
champion che tour c'est possible avec
les division 2 et 3 je te crois sur
parole c'est assez incroyable ce qui se
passe grâce à tous les partenaires grâce
à vous aussi qui nous
regardez nos amis de Hings mais surtout
sur surtout le public qui regarde
évidemment n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
aux chaîes à liker à tout faire pour
faire en sorte que tout ça continue
c'est quand même
sympa comment on fait là avec les blanc
ouais je serais aussi un peu embêté à la
place de Maxime mais vous voyez il est
pas nerveux il prend son temps il
réfléchit ben bien sûr que Carlsen est
millionnaire Oliver 770 il a joué 5
matchs ch du monde où il y a il y a plus
d'un million il y a il y a un à 2
million de Price pool à chaque fois plus
les sponsors plus les prix évidemment
qu'il est millionnaire Magnus
Carlsen il est moins riche que Djokovic
mais il est millionnaire c'est sûr
d'ailleurs toute façon c'est c'est tu
peux tu peux aller regarder sur le
site des impôts norvégiens tout est
archi transparent là-bas tu peux avoir
la fortune exacte de Magnus Carlsen si
ça
t'amuse mais ne t'inquiète pas pour lui
alors E5 mais ça c'est un coup
responsable ça ouvre la grande diagonale
j'aime pas du tout c'est pour faire fou
E4 ou ou cavalier E4 et C D6 mais
attention ça peut jouer des tours
attention Maxime dame 2 ok la Gee j'aime
bien si la Jae aime bien je suis obligé
de m'incliner et de dire que la jauge a
raison c le cavalier va revenir ici quoi
que ah si il y a une menace quand même
la menace il faut prendre7 d' prend G4 d
prend G4 tout de suite et pas av une
menass à cause de T prend des
TR cavalier H6 lu de C F5 ou k D4 on a
un beau jeu sur case blanche ou cas
noir c'est vrai que les les second dans
lui coû
ch les second coût très cher Magnus
Carlsen donc effectivement peut-être
qu'il est pas si millionnaire que
ça malheureusement mon cher Tonton
j'aimerais j'adorerais être
millionnaire mais malheureusement je ne
suis pas
millionnaire pourtant je joue mes ma
date de naissance à l'euromillion quand
l'occasion se
présente ça suffit pas ça rentre pas- je
vous dise moi
ouais mais moi aussi ça me ferait
plaisir parce que Maxime est
millionnaire j'en sais rien en
fa je sais pas je sais pas
honnêtement il a gagé beaucoup de Price
pool Maxime donc c'est pas
impossible après on investit dans les
dans les dans les
tournois euh dans il a un coach mental
il investit beaucoup aussi hein donc euh
comment ça se termine il dépense pas
tout ça c'est sûr il met de l'argent de
côté mais euh
euh à quel point j'en sais rien voilà la
fortune de Caren est à plus de 50
millions de
dollars ouais
ouais ben c'est pas
étonnant bah déjà ce qu'il a vendu hein
play Magnus hein ça c'est quand même
bien vendu
hein
oui c'est pas choquant il a des revenus
confortables ça c'est certain
mais à quel point j'en sais j'en sais
trop rien
honnêtement dame 2 cavalier H6 et tour
D1 joué par Maxime qui conteste la
colonne et bien ma fois c'est très
logique il est pas il a pas très bien
géré
ça
non alors là ça me rapporte rien que si
tout le monde s'abonne je je suis pas
millionnaire mais en tout cas ça ça
m'apporte rien si ça m'apporte de
commenter plus
évidemment
alors tour des un
jouer mais en tout cas ouais c'est des
beaux prix écoutez c'est le modèle
américain aussi hein on peut pas oublier
que chcom est est une compagnie
américaine donc il mettre des beaux
prix c'est aussi valorisé l'ensemble des
joueurs d'échec en en faisant en sorte
que les meilleurs d'entre eux les
meilleurs d'entre nous gagnent beaucoup
d'argent c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
pour tout le monde pour tous ceux qui
vivent grâce aux échecs c'est
sûr
alors comment on va faire c D4 ou
cavalier
F5 je sais pas pas quelque chose comme
ça
certainement il réfléchit Magnus il est
fort dans ses positions
normalement je sais pas trop ce qu'il va
faire que dit la geoge l'oracle dit k
des4 mais k des4 le problème c'est que
c'est pas mal hein dans une partie
normale je dirais qu' des4 tous les
jours mais ah est-ce que je peux prendre
du pion peut-être pour éventuellement
faire k F5 et E3 et c'est jouer ah ah
voyez puis on prend cavalier E4 est-ce
que cavalier F5 est bon là c F5 est
archi tentant quand
même pour faire cavalier E3 cavalier F5
jouer tour F3 et on va se jeter sur le
premier perpétuel qui
vient il joue quand même très très vite
hein
alors comment on fait
maintenant K3 par exemple est pas bon
hein je pense qu'il a K F6 et là c'est
mat là ça rigole plus soit f pr 7 soit
même ça c'est matin
ah bon ça fait que nul ça
ouais même ah faut prendre C échec était
mieux je me suis un peu déconcentré
là fini il fait F prendre 4 ouais il a
il a senti évidemment Magnus Carsen tout
le danger potentiel dans le dans ce
cavalier qui pouvait bondir à n'importe
quel moment F6 et donc sur foupr il va
faire Caval li ah non il peut
pas 3 il a faut pr H7 je pense ah ça
marche
pas
et oui il y a ça et sur damage 7 et roi
F7
ok ok ok pas si simple
l'istoire donc F prend 4 jouer Maxime
réfléchit sur dame prend le 4 il va
jouer G6 évidemment
le
le champion
norvégien et cavalier3 va certainement
arriver c'est vrai qu'il y a plus de G4
parce que pion H7 j'ai qure menaces ici
hein donc faut absolument faire
G6 c'est
vrai tout à fait Georg merci dans le
chat on sent la fin de journée là les
gens remercient c'est très gentil en
tout cas très apprécié le max de Laurent
est 100 points moins élevé que le max de
Maxime c'est tout à fait vrai je pense
qu'il a 2819 j'ai
2721 c'est ça c'est
logique je suis
complètement
complètement c'est faire je pense en
plus c'est ça c'est dans la
carrière ça résume bien la carrière en
fait sans point L c'est ça ça toujours
d'ailleurs en ce moment voilà il a 2727
j'ai 2643 on a une centaine de
points c'est à peu près ça
logique le pic hein dit beaucoup hein
sur les joueurs jusqu'où on est capable
d'aller donc on voit euh Maxime il est
capable d'aller jusqu'à 2820 il y a
quandbien de joueurs d' sur euh il y a
pas beaucoup de joueurs qui sont qui
sont capables d'aller jusqu'à 282 il y a
pas beaucoup qui ont réussi ouh là
ça
marche il dit que ça marche mvl mais ça
ne marche
pas il fallait faire F6 pas F5
apparemment oh là là attention il menace
dame G6 et dame prend a 6 c'est nul
d'après la qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire
il fallait jouer F6
pourquoi que sur tour h6 il av pas dame
G6 dame prend6 qui
menacait quelle
erreur mais regardez il a joué le coup
évident qu'on jouerait tous F5 à tempo
avec 9 minutes à la pendu alors que F6
était une vraie option et maintenant
Maxime il fait ça roi F7 tour H6 et
menace dame G6 et sur roi7 il y a dame
prend6 mat c'est toute la différence
magnifique
incroyable incroyable ce qui se passe
encore un raté de Magnus Carlsen là
alors si je fais
ça mais alors cette jauge
là est-ce que je voyez ça ça et là je
cours je me suis planqué j'ai une pièce
de plus bon je mets le coup 8 il change
complètement d'avis notre ami notre ami
l'oracle il dit ça ah ouais mais
n'importe quoi
cettee lauge est sous le sous le stress
de la de ce match même la jauge ah non
ça y est remet égal
wouh c'est ça qui va se passer le coup
prend mais lae mais il a d G6 sur c'est
mat c'est toute la différence avec l'
ligne on pouit faire avec le pion 6 et
parce que roi 7 dame prend 6 échec et
mat et sur roi G8 évidemment que Maxime
il va prendre la
nul il est bien il serait bien content
de cette fin il va jouer8 Magnus
cararlsen à mon avis quoi d'autre est-ce
que à tour G8 et un coup aussi non ça ça
et dame G6
fini ça ça ou que c'est joli calcule
vite Maxim quand
même les pot de banane en permanence
qu'est-ce que ça
joue qu'est-ce que ça
joue c'est fou de jouer F5 tempo ils ont
pas vu F6 les deux je sais pas si c'est
fou c'est quand
même alors on va analyser ça mon avis
c'est88 va jouer je vous
l'annonce pardon je plus est-ce que ça
est
jouable
d pr
7 nordi mais mieux pour les
noirs et bien et bien non mais il va
jouer qui joue vous êtes marrant il va
jouer8 c'est
sûr encore dis donc ça aurait été
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout le suspense
les deux joueurs ro 8 et le coup humain
qui va être
joué à moins qu'il rate encore dis il
rate tout aujourd'hui vous me direz ça
ça perd aussi à cause de ça et ça bon ça
c'est pas très dur quand même non il
peut rater ça c'est ratable ça c'est un
truc que je peux rater moi dame
G6 ah ça c'est un truc que Maxime il VO
en 2
secondes
mais la ligne principale a l'air quand
même donc t prend roi des7 tour d l'
tellement forcé
ça d B7 la met cavalier3 mais là le
problème c'est que le pion d encore en
vie on a beau avoir beaucoup moins de
pion il y a jamais trop de PERP le
roieva se planquer là et puis ce pion là
il va filer ça ça compqu quand même pour
les pour les Noirs il a joué quoi il a
joué dame prend C4 qui est une énorme
gaffe tour F6 38 et il fait non il a
l'air surpris Maxime et dame prend G7 oh
là là il rate tout et le français qui va
l'emporter ah il rate tout il r tout
c'est incroyable dame C5 il a tour prend
et il peut être fier de lui Maxime il a
supposé les problèmes tour prend F6 il a
beaucoup m calcul que Magnus Carl
aujourd'hui
incroyable incroyable là vraiment c'est
pas pas très dur qu'est-ce qu'il a vu il
a vu d G6 c'est ça et ro des il cro qu'
gag
ouais pas très impressionnant là d pr
jou à tempo par
mvl qui a calculé de manière
incroyable
ouais il craque à chaque fois mais bon
il est quand
même il est quand même assez énorme
Maxime il fait pas il donne rien il
donne rien et abandon
de Magnus Carlsen et
victoire de Maxime vach la grave qui va
s certainement aller un interview sur la
chaîne anglaise que vous pouvez aller
voir bravo Maxime qui a été é non
seulement énorme aujourd'hui bah deux
fois Magnus Carlsen c'est quand même pas
donné à tout le monde mais qui a été
énorme tout au long du tournoi regardez
le braquet et Maxime Vaz La Grave le
beau drapeau français qui flotte sur
cette artificial
intelligence Cup Maxime vachagve qui
aura battu deux fois qui aura mis un 4
et demi 1 et demi aujourd'hui à Magnus
Carlsen c'est pas donné à tout le monde
et un ticket pour Toronto pour max va
chez la grave on va voir regardez ça
Toronto du 9 au 16 décembre c'est lui il
ira et il jouera pour il a gagné ce beau
trophée qui est de la NFT ou pas j'en
sais
rien mais il est assez il a été très
très impressionnant très appliqué alors
on peut toujours dire que Magnus a
Magnus a simplement beaucoup moins bien
calculé que que que Maxim aujourd'hui ça
fait par
ça fait partie du jeu très clairement
bravo à lui vraiment félicitations c'est
d'excellent augur avant il va jouer la
Coupe d'Europe qui commence
après-demain la Coupe d'Europe commence
dimanche il va jouer avec son club
Danier le club français auquel on
souhaite évidemment bonne chance comme à
tous les autres clubs français un des
favoris de la compète et ensuite il va
jouer à l'Î de qui ser sa dernière
chance pour jouer au candidat
pour moi il est temps de vous remercier
évidemment de féliciter une nouvelle
fois maximagve qui a été incroyable tout
au long de la semaine même mercredi
quand il a perdu il a été il a été
dingue et il mérite très largement sa
victoire et évidemment de vous remercier
à vous pour votre patience votre
engouement votre
bienveillance pour tout et je espère à
très bientôt je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée un excellent weekend
et bravo Maxime Vaz La Grave Ciao
ciaoirp
perance
withir
[Musique]